bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
sur l'antenne de public sénat pour
suivre cet après-midi deux discussions
autour de textes importants tout d'abord
le projet de loi égalité femmes hommes
ce texte qui a été présenté en conseil
des ministres il ya un an par la
ministre najat vallaud belkacem et bien
arrive au terme de son parcours
législatif ce projet de loi égalité
femmes hommes devrait être adopté
définitivement par le parlement cet
après-midi et notamment par le sénat
alors je vous rappelle que ce texte vise
à renforcer la parité notamment dans les
partis politiques mais aussi les
conseils d'administration des
entreprises et également les médias un
projet de loi qui vise aussi à renforcer
la lutte contre les violences conjugales
et pitié instaure aussi un nouveau
dispositif expérimental sur le paiement
ou le non paiement plutôt des pensions
alimentaires donc je vous propose tout
de suite de rejoindre l'hémicycle
poursuivre bien la discussion la fin la
discussion de l'adoption définitive de
ce texte entre sur l'égalité femmes
hommes et puis après cette discussion et
bien nous suivrons la discussion autour
d'une proposition de loi très attendue
cet après midi au sénat sur les taxis et
les vtc une position du sénat qui est
attendue puisqu'elle permettrait un peu
plus de concilier les positions entre
les taxis et les vtc leur permettre de
continuer à travailler ensemble ou en
tout cas en parallèle donc très bonne
séance à tous sur notre antenne
l'ordre du jour mesdames et messieurs
appel l'examen des conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire chargée
d'élaborer un texte sur les dispositions
restant en discussion du projet de loi
pour l'égalité réelle entre les femmes
et les hommes dans la discussion
générale
la parole est à madame virginie klès
rapporteur pour le sénat de la
commission mixte paritaire chers
collègues vous avez la parole
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le sénateur et président de la
commission des lois et mes chers
collègues que féminine présente ici je
pense que vous ne m'en voudrez pas si je
au pardon je ne vous avais plein de vie
vous étiez trop loin sans ma droite je
le retire je pense que vous ne m'en
voudrez pas si je commence par un bref
exposé historique je commenterai pas
jusqu'à la préhistoire mais quand même
jusqu'au milieu du xvième siècle dans le
désordre sans faire les choses de façon
forcément très très détaillée mais
plutôt en émaillant mon propos
d'anecdotes de faits qu'il me semble
particulièrement important est en tout
cas éclairant par rapport au texte de
loi que nous examinons aujourd'hui en
tout cas aux résultats de la cmp je vais
commencer par l' ordonnance du 21 avril
1944 on a déjà dû l'a rappelé des
milliers de fois cette ordonnance qui
donnait le droit de vote aux femmes mais
on oublie souvent que c'était aux femmes
mais aussi aux militaires qui finalement
à l'époque étaient considérés comme les
femmes pour n'avoir pas suffisamment
d'esprit critique par eux mêmes et pour
nous donc pas être plus en plus que les
femmes en droit de voter donc finalement
militaire et femmes ont obtenu le même
statut et le même droit de vote en même
temps c'était le 21 avril 1944 et puis
de l'eau a coulé sous les ponts et dans
les années 60 les manuels scolaires
fleurissaient est notamment l'un d'entre
eux que j'ai choisi presque au hasard
mais pas tout à fait qu'ils étaient
destinés aux femmes et qui s'appelait
économie domestique pour les femmes donc
celui-là il était publié en 1960 j'ai
pas tout vous dire simplement quelques
quelques extraits parce qu'ils sont
quand même assez intéressant pour voir
l'évolution entre 44 et 60
alors ça a commencé par ça commençait ce
que j'ai voulu dire commence par fait en
sorte que le souper soit près de winne
et on s'adressait bien évidemment aux
femmes préparer les choses à l'avance le
soir précédent s'il le faut afin qu'un
délicieux repas l'attendent monsieur à
son retour du travail c'est une façon de
lui faire savoir que vous avez pensé à
lui et que vous vous souciez de ses
besoins la plupart des hommes enfin
lorsqu'il rentre à la maison et la
perspective d'un bon repas
particulièrement son plat favori c'est
parti de là nécessaire chaleur d'un
accueil
soyez prêtes prenez 15 minutes pour vous
reposer afin d'être détendu lorsqu'ils
rentrent retoucher votre maquillage
mettez un ruban dans vos cheveux madame
la ministre vous aurez du mal et soyez
fraîche et avenante il a passé la
journée en compagnie de jean surchargé
de soucis et de travail donc soyez
enjoué et un peu plus intéressante que
ces derniers ça dure journée a besoin
d'être égayer et c'est un de vos devoir
de faire en sorte qu'elle le soit
pendant les mois les plus froids de
l'année il vous faudra préparer et
allumer le feu dans la cheminée auprès
duquel il puisse se détendre votre mari
aura le sentiment d'avoir atteint un
havre de repos est d'ordre et cela vous
rendra également heureuse puisque en
définitive veiller à son confort vous
procurera une immense satisfaction
personnelle
révisé tous les bruits au minimum au
moment de son arrivée éliminer tout
bruit de machine à laver de séchoir à
linge ou d'aspirateurs essayé
d'encourager des enfants être calme
soyez heureuse de le voir accueillez le
avec un chaleureux sourire et montrer de
la sincérité dans votre désir de lui
plaire écoutez le il se peut que vous
ayez une douzaine de choses importantes
à lui dire mais son arrivée à la maison
n'est pas le moment opportun laissez le
parler d'abord souvenez vous que ces
sujets de conversation sont plus
importants que les vôtres fait en sorte
que la soirée lui appartiennent et
surtout ne vous plaignez jamais s'il
rentre tard à la maison ou s'il sort
pour dîner ou pour aller dans d'autres
lieux de divertissement sans vous au
contraire essayer de faire en sorte là
encore que votre foyer soit pas un havre
de paix d'autres et de tranquillité ou
votre mari puisse étendre son corps et
son esprit ne l'accueillez pas avec vos
plaintes et vos problèmes ne vous
plaignez pas s'il est en retard à la
maison pour le souper ou même s'ils
restent dehors toute la nuit considérez
cela comme mineur comparé à ce qu'il a
pu endurer pendant la journée
installez le confortablement proposez
lui de se détendre dans une chaise
confortable ou d'aller s'éteindre dans
la chambre à coucher préparez lui une
boisson fraîche ou chaude arranger
l'oreiller proposez lui d'enlever ses
souliers parler d'une voix douce
apaisante et plaisante ne lui posez pas
de questions sur ce qu'il a fait et ne
remettez jamais en cause son jugement ou
son intégrité souvenez vous qu'il est le
maître du foyer et qu'en tant que tel il
exercera toujours sa justice avec sa
volonté pardon avec justice et honnêteté
lorsqu'il a fini de souper débarrasser
la table et fait rapidement la vaisselle
si votre mari se propose de vous aider
décliné son offre car il risquerait de
se sentir obligé de la répéter par la
suite et après une longue journée de
labeur il n'a nul besoin de travail
supplémentaires
bien que l'hygiène féminine soit d'une
grande importance
votre mari fatigué ne se réfère la queue
devant la salle de bain comme ils
l'auraient à le faire pour prendre son
train cependant assurez vous d'être
d'être à votre meilleur avantage en
allant vous couchez essayer d'avoir une
apparence qui soit avenante sans être
aguicheuse si vous devez vous appliquer
de la crème sur le visage ou mettre des
bigoudis attendait son sommeil car cela
pourrait le choquer de s'endormir sur un
tel spectacle
je vous passe peut-être les détails sur
si votre mari suggère de relations
intimes experts exceptions vous le
trouverez sur internet de toutes façons
non vous voulez la suite
bon alors je vais pas tout vous lire
mais peut-être quand même si votre mari
vous suggère l'accouplement accepté
alors avec humilité tout en gardant à
l'esprit que le plaisir d'un homme est
plus important que celui d'une femme
lorsqu'il atteint l'orgasme un petit
gémissement de votre part l'encouragera
et sera tout à fait suffisant pour
indiquer toute forme de plaisir que vous
ayez pu avoir vous pouvez alors remonté
le réveil afin d'être debout peu de
temps avant lui le matin cela vous
permettra de tenir sa tasse de thé du
matin à sa disposition lorsqu'il se
réveillera 1960 c'est quand même pas si
vieux que ça je suis né très peu de
temps après et je pense qu'il ya
quelques manuels scolaires de ce type là
encore pendant les quelques années qui
ont suivi depuis c'était sans doute très
bien je je je pensais bien que j'aurai
quelques approbation masculine quand
même dans l'assemblée
depuis malgré tout les choses ont un peu
bougé et aujourd'hui on s'interroge
parfois aussi sur le rôle notamment de
la première dame en france on s'est
encore jamais interrogée ce rôle d'un
éventuel premier monsieur mais bon on
s'interroge sur celui d'une première
dame et j'aimerais quand même rappeler
dans cette enceinte que l'on pourrait
peut-être réfléchir à ce qu'il y a
vraiment un rôle à tenir pour une
première dame ou un premier monsieur en
france sachant que la loi ni fait
explicitement mention que pour les
courriers des détenus qui lorsqu'ils
sont adressés à l'épousé du président de
la république ne peuvent pas être
ouverts mais c'est la seule référence
dans notre arsenal de textes à l'époux
ou l'épousé du président de la
république on est en 2014 et malgré tout
en 2014 moi j'ai encore entendu des
jeunes femmes autour de moi et très
récemment elles se reconnaîtront
certaines d'entre elles me dire bah
ouais quand il a fallu que je choisisse
que je me fasse un plan de carrière je
me suis dit que si je souhaitais telle
carrière je serai obligé de déménager
tous les deux ou trois ans et je me suis
dit que mon mari ne me suivrait pas donc
j'ai choisi notre carrière moins
intéressante mais j'ai choisi de ne pas
faire bouger mon mari tous les deux ou
trois ans
heureusement quand même j'ai aussi des
exemples contraires
au tour au cours des rencontres ou des
anecdotes qui ont été rapportés ces
temps ci j'ai par exemple rencontré il
ya déjà une vingtaine ou trentaine
d'années un praticien une praticienne
hospitalière qui a été mariée avec un
moniteur d'auto école qui a eu trois
enfants et la stupéfaction générale de
tout son entourage
madame la ministre je serais très
content que si elle était là aujourd'hui
parce que c'est son mari qui a choisi de
prendre un congé parental pour garder
les enfants je vous donnerai ses
coordonnées si vous voulez aller la voir
un jour avec le nouveau texte de loi en
l'occurrence je connais aussi même des
administrateurs au sein du sénat qui
parfois s'en charge et garder leurs
enfants et qui parfois du coup font des
allers retours entre des réunions au
sénat la garde des enfants et ceux des
gouttes quand même pour que le boulot
soit fait en temps et en heure même si
l'effet sur des moments de congés ou sur
des moments plus tardif encore dans la
nuit donc malgré tout on avance
l'expression de prince consort
qui existe quand même de plus en plus
vous savez le mari de madame ou le
conjoint de madame c'est quoi ce qu'on
sorte qu'il se rend compte qu'ils
parlent entre eux qui généralement en
plaisante un petit peu
mais qui aujourd'hui c'est sans doute un
progrès se font appeler aussi par les
services de formation des madame
justement et notamment j'ai récemment
entendu parler d'un monsieur marié avec
une préfète et qui se fait appeler par
le service de formation qui lui
proposait gentiment on place dans la
formation destinée aux épouses des
préfets avec un programme extrêmement
intéressant c'est la seule chose qui me
pourquoi pas bien sûr la seule chose qui
me soucie impôts c'est qu' il n'avait
pas imaginé une seule minute que la
personne en question puisse travailler
et on lui proposait d'apprendre à faire
des plans table on lui proposait
d'apprendre à recevoir on y propose est
d'apprendre le protocole etc etc mais
c'est aujourd'hui un traitement qui est
réservé aussi bien aux épouses épouse
après tout voyons s'il a un avantage
voyons voyons zilla pardon un pas en
avant encore
après tout c'est peut-être l'égalité
supérieur on va parler aujourd'hui
d'égalité real ce sera peut-être égalité
supérieur nous demain tout ceci pour
vous dire que quand je vous ai dit je
remonterai un milieu du xvième siècle il
y avait quand même quelqu'un au milieu
du xvième siècle qui était certainement
très très en avance et qui aurait sans
doute été heureux d'être ici aujourd'hui
c'était montaigne montagne qui a quand
même écrit les femmes ont raison de se
rebeller contre les lois parce que nous
les avons fait sans elle
est aujourd'hui heureusement quelques
hommes nous ont rejoints parce que sinon
j'aurais dit ne les faisons pas non plus
ses doigts sans les hommes ou alors
considérons qu'ils ont tellement
confiance en nous qu'on peut les faires
s'en veut et qu'on réussira malgré tout
un très beau texte pour revenir
justement à ce texte manama ministre et
de façon cette fois ci beaucoup plus
sérieuse et aux conclusions de la cmp
qui je vous rassure a abouti à un texte
que je vous propose que je vais vous
proposer au vote tout à l'heure un
certain nombre restait une trentaine
d'articles plus lente et de l'intitulé
du texte de loi en discussion sur 7 sur
cette cmp sur un certain nombre
d'articles je ne vais pas tout vous
redétaillé les différences entre
l'écriture assemblée nationale et
l'écriture sonnette et essentiellement
deux formes ou des questions de dates ou
des références juridiques qu'il fallait
modifier cet effet est très bien fait
par nos collègues de l'assemblée le
sénat aussi à réviser encore les
quelques peut-être dernière petite chose
jusqu'au dernier moment et il restait à
la fin 18 points seulement sur lesquels
il avait une discussion de fond à avoir
et sur lesquels nous avons trouvé des
accords alors je vais pas prendre les
choses dans l'ordre du texte j'ai plutôt
prendre les choses dans l'ordre des
accords donc le texte de l'assemblée
nationale a été adopté par la commission
mixte paritaire sur l'article de bild b
c'est-à-dire l'opportunité de donner des
autorisations d'absence de permettre au
futur père de bénéficier d'autorisations
de l'absence pour se rendre aux examens
prénataux de leur compagne dans la
limite de 3 donc sur ce point là nous
sommes tombés d'accord sans forcément
être archi convaincu que cette mesure
permettra aux pères de s'investir très
en amont en tout cas certains d'entre
eux d'investir très en amont
dans la venue d'un enfant à la maison
mais en tout cas ça permettra à certains
d'entre eux de le faire plus facilement
donc c'est une bonne mesure et le sénat
c'est donc ralliée à la position de
l'assemblée sur le sujet sur l'article 2
bis des et sur la bpi avec un objectif
d'encouragement à l'entrepreneuriat
féminin nous étions d'accord sur le fond
c'est simplement à la rédaction qui a vu
des modifications
proposée par le sénat revient une
simplification des mesures qui étaient
proposées
un article qui avait été beaucoup
discuté en commission des lois qui
consistait en la le remplacement de la
notion de bon père de famille d'antonio
texte de loi par le terme de raisonnable
le sénat avait choisi d'autres termes
prudent et diligent si je me rappelle
bien qu'ils avaient été proposées par
notre collègue esther benbassa et
finalement le sénat s'est rallié au
terme de raisonnable ou raisonnablement
qui avait déjà des antécédents entre
d'imagés juridique si je peux m'exprimer
ainsi et qui nous a paru après tout
suffisamment parlants pour se rallier là
encore à l'adoption de l'assemblée
nationale sur le versement de la pension
alimentaire alors salle et nos collègues
de l'assemblée nationale il tenait
beaucoup tenait beaucoup à ce que la
notion de virements bancaires
apparaissent dans le texte de loi en
nous disant qu'il existait de nombreux
cas dans lesquels après une séparation
monsieur se montrait récalcitrants pour
verser régulièrement à la pension
alimentaire et prenait un malin plaisir
à faire en sorte que son ex épouse ou
son ex compagne doivent la lui réclamé
plusieurs fois avant de l'obtenir tous
les mois et le virement bancaire qui
était déjà de fait autorisé sand est
explicitement cité dans la loi
aujourd'hui mettait déjà de fait
autorisé n'était semble-t-il pas
suffisamment utilisé ou pas suffisamment
connue par les juges qui ordonne les
conventions et les règlements de pension
alimentaire donc sur l'insistance de nos
collègues de l'assemblée nationale nous
avons donc introduit le terme de
virement bancaire de façon très
explicite dans la loi pour permettre le
versement des pensions alimentaires mais
nous avons rajouté nous avons tenu au
sénat rajouter d'ailleurs ou tout autre
mode de paiement dans la mesure où tout
le monde ne dispose pas d'un compte
bancaire quand les séparations lieu les
comptes bancaires sont pas forcément
toujours dit soins il peut y avoir des
personnes en interdit bancaire pour
lesquels le virement bancaire est une
impossibilité aussi de règlement voilà
donc je pense que l'objectif de nos
collègues de l'assemblée nationale est
atteint on pensera peut-être plus
souvent en virement bancaire mais pour
autant tous les autres modes de paiement
de la pension alimentaire sont à la
disposition du juge pour être positionné
dans les conventions
accords aussi sur la version de
l'assemblée nationale pour les
procédures de récuser de récusation
pardon en matière de procédures
disciplinaires univers six ter là il n'y
avait pas de souci majeur sur le sujet
sur l'article 17 qui était un amendement
porté par madame tasca et qui concernait
la diffusion d'image de violences aux
personnes sur internet là encore nous
nous sommes rendus aux arguments de nos
collègues de l'assemblée nationale tout
en voulant attirer aujourd'hui
l'attention du gouvernement par votre
intermédiaire madame la ministre sur ce
sujet là qui est un sujet important
madame tasca devise est dans son
amendement les images violentes
prises par les adolescents de plus en
plus malheureusement
qu'ils sortent leur portable et qui sont
d'ailleurs incité aujourd'hui à sortir
leur portable au moindre événement un
peu inhabituel qui se déroule autour
d'eux et a filmé la scène et puis à la
mettre sur internet indépendamment de ce
genre de scène qui se fait
volontairement dans le cadre du
harcèlement etc
c'est un comportement qui n'est pas
excusable c'est un comportement qu'on ne
peut pas encourager et l'objectif d'
adam tasca était d' affirmer très
clairement par le retrait et le blocage
de ces sites décident qu'ils portaient
ces images à le blocage par les
fournisseurs d'accès internet indiqué de
façon très très clairs notamment aux
jeunes coutumier de ce genre de pratique
que c'était une pratique interdite
dangereuses etc etc nos collègues de
l'assemblée à juste titre nous ont fait
remarquer que les fournisseurs d'accès
internet n'ont pas les moyens juridiques
de vérifier la réalité des images en
question et que une scène de violence
peut être feinte simuler peut-être une
comédie peut-être une farce certes de
mauvais goût mais une farce quand même
fait par des jeunes et que le blocage
des sites qui fournissait ses images en
prêt mais la responsabilité pénale des
fameux fournisseurs d'accès internet
donc pour ces raisons nous sommes rendus
aux arguments de nos collègues de
l'assemblée effectivement nous sommes
donc revenus à leur écriture en
supprimant cette disposition
mais il semble qu'il ya quand même la
madame la ministre vraiment peut-être
dans le cadre du projet de loi
terrorisme qui va arriver qu'ils
traitent je le sais de ces sujets
puisque l'assemblée nationale elle même
à traiter il y avait des amendements je
crois sur sur ce type de sujet hier ou
très récemment il a vraiment une
articulation avoir entre la
responsabilité des fournisseurs d'accès
internet et les moyens qu'on leur donne
d'exercer leurs responsabilités
c'est-à-dire de vérifier l'origine des
images alors est ce que c'est à eux de
le faire à une autorité judiciaire je ne
sais pas j'ai pas la réponse aujourd'hui
mais il ya clairement une articulation à
trouver entre les émissions de ces
images leur vérification et
l'interdiction éventuelle d'accès ou le
blocage des sites par les fournisseurs
d'accès internet il ya là un véritable
enjeu d'éducation nous semble-t-il même
si nous avons effectivement nous avons
une fois plus aux arguments de nos
collègues de l'assemblée pour être
d'accord sur le fait que c'était sans
doute pas le montech ce n'est pas le bon
moment
l'utilisation du nom ni dans les
relations des usagers avec
l'administration
aujourd'hui ça existe déjà je vais pas
vous raconter encore l'histoire mais
aujourd'hui c'est déjà le cas il
n'empêche que c'est pas connu mal
connues méconnues voire parfois fouler
du pied encore une anecdote quelqu'un
d'autre qui m'a raconté que à l'occasion
d'un renouvellement de chéquiers le nom
de son épouse avait disparu des
chéquiers pour qu'il ne portait plus que
son nom à lui donc clairement cette
disposition est méconnu donc après tout
de la réécrire clairement dans la loi
qui sort aujourd'hui n'est pas une
mauvaise chose même si initialement nous
n'y étions pas forcément très favorable
je reconnais que moi même je ressens
encore des papiers de la sécurité
sociale au nom de mon ex mari alors que
j'ai même jamais utilisé ce nom là dans
la vie courante donc clairement il faut
peut-être réaffirmé effectivement les
choses
sur
l'objectif de parité aux membres de
l'institut de chacune des académies et
le sénat s'est rallié là aussi à la
position de l'assemblée
l'assemblée s'est ralliée à la position
du sénat sur un certain nombre d'autres
points et notamment sur l'article 18 bis
qui posait un objectif de parité à la
tête des exécutifs locaux autrement dit
le maire était un homme le premier
adjoint était une femme et vice versa et
c'est donc là très clairement pour nous
il y avait un souci de
constitutionnalité puisque ce sont deux
élections qui a priori ne doivent pas
être liés donc égalité de candidature
total sur ces deux élections et à partir
du moment où le sexe de la première
personne fall le sexe du premier adjoint
du premier vice-président était
dépendant du résultat de la première
élection on ne respectait plus ce
principe d'égalité des candidatures donc
la mort dans l'âme certes mais nos
collègues de l'assemblée nationale ce
sont là aussi rallier à notre position
toujours en matière d'élection la date
d'entrée en vigueur des dispositions qui
clarifie les règles de remplacement des
conseillers communautaires on comprenait
pas bien pourquoi il fallait attendre le
1er janvier 2015 alors que c'est une
mesure qui est très attendu sur le
terrain simplifier un petit peu les
choses et permettre que parfois une
femme puisse remplacer un homme dans les
conseillers communautaires
démissionnaire ce qu'ils ont dit dans le
texte tel qu'il est tel qu'ils élucident
nos travaux n'est pas possible donc là
dessus l'assemblée nationale s'est aussi
ralliée à nos arguments
l'instauration de la parité dans les
cons cette administration de tous les
établissements publics locaux même si
sur le fond et sur le principe on a
envie de dire oui bien sûr il faut mais
dans la réalité et dans la pratique est
dans le concret c'est malheureusement au
jour d'aujourd'hui impossible parce que
les hits les conseils d'administration
des établissements publics locaux c'est
les caisses des écoles c'est les ccas
c'est les conseils d'administration des
collèges et des lycées et instaurer une
parité entre guillemets de force d'abord
c'est pas forcément possible dans les
toutes petites communes je parle là des
conseils d'école ou des ccas pour
lesquels la parité n'est elle même pas
présente dans les conseils municipaux et
puis ensuite ce sont des nominations par
des instances nominative différentes
donc là il n'y a malheureusement pas
possibilité au jour d'aujourd'hui
d'avancer d'une façon brutale sur ce
sujet sur l'article 21 où nos collègues
de l'assemblée souhaitait un principe de
nullité des nominations aux emplois
d'encadrement de la fonction publique
qui serait intervenue en violation de
l'obligation de parité là encore même si
on avait envie de dire oui sur le
principe ça posait d'énormes problèmes
constitutionnels peut-être à l'assemblée
la n'a pas voulu entendre ses arguments
là mais en tout état de cause des
problèmes concrets et pratiques
de décision en dominos peut-être de
retour de certaines personnes pour des
raisons qui ne concerne absolument pas
des traitements inférieur à ce qu'ils
avaient par le dispositif même tels
qu'ils étaient proposés à savoir la
parité à tout moment une vérification
une fois par an et donc des nullités de
nomination qui serait arrivé à
intervenue une fois par an seulement
donc ça posait un tel problème aussi une
fois plus pratique et concret que là
encore nos collègues de l'assemblée ont
accepté de nous suivre il n'y a que pour
les
circonstances où ça ne me pose pas de
souci que cette obligation aujourd'hui
est imposé sur le dernier article qui
est règle article 23 par non pas le
dernier sur l'article 23 qui est très
technique et qui autorise le
gouvernement à légiférer par ordonnances
pour instaurer la parité dans un certain
nombre d'instances là encore nous sommes
nous avons trouvé un compromis un accord
avec l'assemblée nationale à savoir le
gouvernement légifèrera par ordonnance
pour les autorités administratives
indépendantes et les autorités publiques
indépendantes donc autorité par
autorités et par contre pour l'ensemble
des instances consultatives collégiale
une disposition ballet est maintenu et
va nous permettre aussi d'avancer sur le
sujet
oui je me dépêche madame la présidente
j'en ai presque terminé j'avais presque
tas mais j'ai plus que trois points à
voir sur la tique le sait telle
ordonnance de protection un désaccord
subsiste et aussi sur la possibilité
pour les femmes victimes de violence est
protégée par une ordonnance de
protection dissimuler leur domicile
c'est possible aujourd'hui
la demande qui était faite était de les
autoriser à se domicilier chez une
personne morale qualifier autrement dit
dans une association nous avons au sénat
des réticences sur le sujet nous pensons
que ça risque de les mettre encore plus
en danger parce que de vieux remettre en
évidence mais d'autres nos collègues
notamment de l'assemblée nationale
estimait que c'était une solution qui
allait permettre d'avancer sur le sujet
c'est une possibilité c'est pas une
obligation donc c'est cette disposition
qui a été retenu ainsi que l'obligation
de parité dans les conseils
d'administration ou de surveillance des
sociétés anonymes non cotées en les
avançant à 2017 au lieu de 2000 côté par
mon 2017 au lieu de 2020 et pour les non
cotées en étendant cette obligation pour
les entreprises de 250 à 499 salariés il
reste le titre j'ai souri tout à leur
dossier en parlant des réalités
supérieur et la pleine égalité réelle
nos collègues de l'assemblée tenait au
terme de réelles dans le titre une
égalité réelle en disant cette fois ci
c'est vrai ça va avancer ça va bouger
nous au sénat on tenait plutôt à
l'égalité comme notre devise liberté
égalité fraternité mais l'assument ce
président sur se fera sans doute un
plaisir tout à l'heure de vous vous
donnez un argumentaire beaucoup plus
détaillé que le mien en tout état de
cause avec ou sans hommes c'est une très
belle loi merci madame la ministre je
vous engage à la beauté dans ses
versions sorties de la cmp merci madame
la rapporteure
la parole est à mme adam nash est
valable najat vallaud belkacem excusez
moi même la milice ministre des droits
des femmes de la ville de la jeunesse et
des sports
merci madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le président la commission des
lois madame la rapporteure même la
présidente de la délégation aux droits
des femmes
nous sommes en train d'arriver au au
bout d'un travail qui est véritablement
à l'odeur du parlement et je le dis en
pesant chaque mot avec beaucoup de
simplicité beaucoup d'humilité et en
même temps de reconnaissance parce que
vous avez été les avant-gardes les têtes
de pont les premières lignes du combat
pour les droits des femmes j'en ai été
témoin ici même lorsque au mois de juin
juillet 2012 déjà nous discutions nous
disputions du texte contre le
harcèlement sexuel
ce projet de loi cadre
c'est une première et j'espère que c'est
un commencement nous l'avons préparé
ensemble avec un regard neuf avec une
approche totalement intégrée des
politiques d'égalité et une philosophie
de l'action qui je crois répond bien aux
défis de notre temps c'est des filles ce
sont ceux de loi qui s'applique ce sont
ceux de loi sur l'égalité qui sont
respectés mais c'est aussi le défi du
changement des mentalités d'un partage
nouveau des responsabilités parentales
d'une exigence de parité qui soit enfin
pleinement effective je vous avais
demandé au commencement de cet examen
d'affirmer avec moi et vous l'avez fait
l'ambition de réaliser l'égalité réelle
c'est une ambition qui est très attendu
par nos concitoyennes en particulier et
c'est vrai que votre commission mixte
paritaire a finalement choisi de retenir
ce titre pour ce projet de loi il prend
tout son sens ce projet de loi c'est la
fête de tous parce que nous y avons
contribué tous ensemble mais au delà
parce que parlement gouvernement
collectivités locales entreprises
citoyens nous en serons tous les garants
et tous les acteurs chacun dans nos
responsabilités
le parlement et chacun des groupes de
vos assemblées
ont apportés à ce projet de loi une
contribution extrêmement précieuse
dans l'esprit d'ailleurs d'une co
construction législatives qui est plutôt
de tradition sur les textes relatifs aux
droits des femmes et que j'espère vous à
les concrétiser à nouveau tout à l'heure
lors de vos votes je veux à cet instant
saluer l'excellent travail de la
rapporteure virginie klès
je veux saluer aussi les contributions
des rapporteurs des commissions saisies
pour alice michel meunier maryvonne
blondin je veux vous dire à toutes les
trois que c'est sous votre impulsion et
j'en ai pleinement pris conscience que
ce texte a tellement progressé a pu
aborder des questions nouvelles et que
votre travail de fond a apporté beaucoup
de sérénité à nos débats je le disais
l'égalité c'est l' affaire de tous et
bien sûr tous les ministères sont
concernés par ce texte qui en réalité
matérialise cette approche
interministérielle dont j'ai voulu faire
un automatisme depuis que j'ai pris mes
responsabilités en 2012 approchent
interministériel parce que je crois que
c'est la condition de la réussite d'un
changement qui investit toutes les
politiques publiques et tous les
secteurs de la société
avec ce projet de loi c'est une
conception nouvelle que nous afficherons
la politique de l'égalité c'est un
ensemble cohérent qui doit combattre en
même temps et dans un même mouvement
toutes les inégalités d'où qu'elles
viennent quel que soit leur mode
d'expression
les violences la précarité des familles
monoparentales la persistance des
inégalités entre les femmes et les
hommes dans le milieu professionnel
comme dans la sphère personnelle ce
texte forme in fine et une belle loi
tout au long de nos débats nous avons
veillé à ce que ça reste une belle loi
et j'en suis heureuse nous y sommes
arrivés nous avons été attentifs à ne
pas la surcharge et de dispositions
bavarde nous l'avons concentrer sur
l'essentiel sur ceux qui créent de la
norme et qui donnera des outils
véritablement nouveau pour gagner en
efficacité et en effectivité cette loi
vous l'avez fait avec nous pour qu'elle
soit un puissant coup d'accélérateur au
mouvement pour l'égalité vous l'avez
fait aussi pour changer très
concrètement la vie de nos concitoyennes
concitoyens dans tous les domaines et je
serai totalement investis pour que cette
loi soit rapidement appliquées nous
publierons je m'y engage l'ensemble des
textes d'application de la loi avant la
fin du mois de novembre
avec la réforme du congé parental nous
mettons grâce à ce texte en place une
logique nouvelles des prestations
sociales qui doivent désormais être
conçue dès le départ avec le réflexe de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
avec la réforme de la négociation en
matière d'égalité professionnelle avec
l'introduction de cette mesure est
essentielle d'interdiction d'accès à la
commande publique pour les entreprises
qui ne jouent pas le jeu de l'égalité
professionnelle
nous allons donner encore plus d'ampleur
au changement que nous avons introduit
depuis deux ans en la matière tout le
monde le sait désormais il n'y a plus
d'impunité pour ceux qui ne respectent
pas leurs obligations en matière
d'égalité professionnelle
c'est un changement de fond qui se joue
là sur lequel les collectivités
publiques sont désormais responsabiliser
et que nous allons poursuivre avec trois
objectifs faire respecter la norme voté
par le parlement dialoguer avec les
partenaires sociaux pour aller encore
plus loin et accompagner les entreprises
comme nous l'avons fait en particulier
dans ses neuf régions d'excellence que
nous avions identifiés il y a deux ans
dans lesquelles nous avons mené un gros
travail dans lesquelles près de 8000
entreprises ont été formés pour
l'essentiel des pme avec des partenaires
sociaux qui sont désormais au rendez
vous pour faire en sorte qu'il y ait
davantage d'accords signés sur l'égalité
professionnelle nous amplifierons bien
entendu cet accompagnement
toutes les enquêtes le montrent et vous
en avez tous témoigner parce que vous le
constatez sur vos territoires les
familles monoparentales sont trop
souvent dans une situation de grande
précarité
et c'est vrai en particulier dans les
territoires de la politique de la ville
où j'ai décidé d'ailleurs de faire de
cette lutte contre la précarité des
familles monoparentales une priorité des
prochains contrats de ville que nous
nous apprêtons à négocier avec les
collectivités et bien grâce à ce projet
de loi si vous l'adoptez en engageant la
mise en oeuvre de la garantie publique
contre les impayés de pension
alimentaire
nous attaquons à une cause bien
identifiés de la précarité des mères
isolées en particulier nous apportons
plus de sécurité à ces femmes à leurs
enfants nous mettrons en place cette
garantie publique contre les impayés de
pension alimentaire d'abord dans 20
départements pour la préfigurer avant de
la généraliser en 2016 je peux vous
confirmer pour être allé les voir sur le
terrain l'engagement très fort des caf
des caisses de msa pardon que je salue
et qui ont bien compris l'intérêt
général qu'il y avait à déployer un
système comme celui là pour mettre fin à
cette précarité
le travail de coproduction législative
c'est sans doute dans le domaine des
violences que nous l'avons poussé le
plus loin avec des améliorations
sensibles
opéré au cours de la navette est
consacrée par la cnd ou venez de le
rappeler madame la rapporteure une
protection renforcée des femmes dans le
cadre de l' ordonnance de protection une
protection renforcée des femmes
étrangères victimes de violences la
définition d'un arsenal législatif de
lutte contre les violences sexuelles
dans l'armée à l'université la lutte
contre le harcèlement moral hors du
cadre du travail l'élargissement du
périmètre du téléphone portable grand
danger aux victimes de viol au delà des
victimes de violences conjugales la
lutte contre les mariages forcés tout
cela est dans ce texte le résultat c'est
une loi qui va vraiment changer la donne
qui apportera plus de protection aux
femmes victimes de violence mais aussi
qui ouvrira des possibilités nouvelles
de prise en charge des auteurs pour
mieux lutter contre la récidive
enfin la parité les évolutions prévues
par le texte seront profondes et
durables n'en doutez pas un instant nous
concrétisons enfin le principe inscrit
dans la constitution de l'égal accès des
femmes et des hommes aux responsabilités
politiques professionnelles et sociales
toutes les institutions de la vie
sociale seront désormais concernés et
les pouvoirs publics eux-mêmes seront
exemplaires pour lutter contre le
plafond de verre dans la fonction
publique nous avons décidé d'avancer
d'un an à 2010 est donc le obligation
d'atteindre 40 % au minimum deux
nominations féminines dans les postes de
cadres dirigeants de la fonction
publique les instances consultatives les
établissements publics administratifs
industriels et commerciaux les autorités
administratives indépendantes toutes ses
instances seront concernés par cette
obligation de féminiser leur personnel
ce qui devrait changer la représentation
des femmes dans l'espace public
en attendant qu'en 2017 les nouvelles
règles que vous avez adopté dans cette
loi change le visage aussi de la
représentation nationale
j'ai compris d'ailleurs que les
principaux partis étaient près par
adhésion ou parfois par souci d'économie
nous verrons mais ce sera sans nul doute
un rendez vous important
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs le
vote que je sollicite auprès de vous
c'est un vote d'adhésion pour un texte
qui se donne les moyens de son ambition
c'est un vote de conviction de
conviction dans la capacité de notre
pays à faire le dernier saut pour offrir
enfin aux françaises et aux français la
perspective de vivre dans une société de
l'égalité réelle je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à madame esther benbassa
pour le groupe écologiste
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mesdames les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues si les états doivent être
naturellement en première ligne pour
améliorer leur législation dans le
domaine de l'égalité femmes hommes et je
vous sais gré madame la ministre dit
avoir contribué par ce projet de loi
pour nos pays c'est bien l'ensemble de
la société qui doivent se saisir de ces
questions au delà c'est encore à chacun
et à chacune d'entre nous à son échelle
deux contribué à remettre en cause les
stéréotypes de genre on me pardonnera ce
mot et les pratiques qui pérennise les
discriminations dont les femmes sont
traditionnellement victimes
qu'on me permette de revenir sur une
question qui pour diverses raisons me
tient particulièrement à coeur celle des
programmes scolaires
maintenant que les abcd de l'égalité ont
quitté l'école sans avoir eu le temps
d'y faire leur chemin l'élaboration de
ces programmes et la tension qu'il
convient d'y apporter sont plus que
jamais primordial
ce sont ces programmes qui fabrique un
savoir qui pour le moment demeure dominé
par le masculin prenons l'exemple de
l'enseignement de l'histoire
traditionnelle piliers idéologiques et
identitaire d'une nation l'histoire le
produit de la mémoire nationale et
façonnent la conscience du citoyen en
herbe appelés à contribuer à la cohésion
nationale
or nous le savons l'histoire enseignée
dans les écoles primaires les collèges
et les lycées à trop lent longtemps été
ges encore largement une histoire des
événements de la succession des règnes
et des régimes
des conquêtes des guerres et des
batailles dans cette histoire là la
femme est le plus souvent invisibles les
manuels du prime elle faisait bien place
traditionnellement à jeanne d'arc jeanne
n'est pourtant grande que parce que
puisse l elle s'efface devant sa mission
le service du roi et de la patrie elle
n'a aucun pouvoir par elle-même et en
outre elle finit bien sûr en victime à
côté deux jeunes d'autres héroïnes
féminines populin peut bien apparaître
tel blandine dévoré par les lions encore
une héroïne victimes viennent ensuite
les régions en général mauvaises elles
sont femmes ou même de roi donc il
n'existe pas par elle-même peu de femmes
créatrices dans ce doute panthéon madame
de sévigné est rarement là madame de la
fayette
la peintre madame vigée le brun ou
camille claudel ne sont jamais évoqués
olympe de gouges jusqu'à récemment
n'était évoqué que dans un unique manuel
dans l'enseignement secondaire nous
avons marie-antoinette veines et frivole
figure emblématique d'une représentation
déprécier des femmes ou alors charlotte
corday la violente type de la mégère des
femmes dans la révolution industrielle
des femmes ouvrières ou ne parlent guère
à croire que la révolution industrielle
fut un acte purement viril or il suffit
de lire germinal de zola pour voir
comment les femmes elles aussi
descendait dans les 1000 si les manuels
récents accords d'un peu plus de place
aux femmes le bilan reste toutefois
mitigé or les manuels reflète des
programmes qui sont fixées au plan
national madame la ministre le rapport
quelle place pour les femmes dans
l'histoire enseignée suggère des remèdes
pour pallier cette absence énoncée en
2000 cas ils ne sont pas encore plus au
sérieux comme il le devrait quant à
l'enseignement de la géographie aussi
bien dans les programmes que dans les
manuels scolaires la présence féminine
lié bien discrète ces disciplines qui
devrait aider à la connaissance du monde
ne fait pas de distinction entre femmes
et hommes
utilisant le thème générique d'hommes
sur cinq manuels pris comme échantillon
4 plaisante des femmes sur leur
couverture
il s'agit essentiellement des femmes au
travail dans les milieux ruraux des pays
du sud elle s'y adonnent au travail de
la terre ou dans les rizières au soin
des bêtes et bien sûr à la préparation
de repas à la garde des enfants ce sont
des femmes exotiques de pays lointains
et lorsque l'on met en avant des femmes
modernes occidentales elles sont le
présenter dans ses murs manuel dans des
moments de détente et associés sauf
exception au passé au bien-être et aux
vacances à y regarder de près on se
demande si toutes ces femmes
occidentales ne sont pas entretenues
pour avoir un tel mode de vie l'image
donnée est nettement partiel et partial
alors même que les programmes de
géographie sont censées répondre à des
objectifs politiques au sens noble de ce
maux liés à la construction même du
projet républicain on pourrait
évidemment étendre cette enquête à
l'enseignement d'autres disciplines mais
je vous épargne parce que c'est encore
pire il reste donc encore beaucoup à
faire ce projet de loi est un précieux
jalons pas une fin en soi ni un
aboutissement
c'est donc en ayant clairement
conscience que le débat doit continuer
que le groupe écologiste le vôtre merci
merci à la sénatrice
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à monsieur andré reichardt
pour le groupe ump
mais ma présidente madame la ministre
madame le rapporteur mes chers collègues
permettez-moi d'abord de me féliciter
d'être le seul orateur home à intervenir
à la tribune dans ce débat pourtant
consacrée à l'égalité entre les femmes
les hommes
cela fait peu cela fait peu
mais à défaut de la quantité permettez
moi j'ai simplement de dire que
peut-être que vous aurez la qualité
mais ce simple constat illustre s'il
fallait à souhait que l'égalité où
l'inégalité entre les femmes et les
hommes a de multiples facettes
ça fait d'ailleurs de nombreuses années
que les gouvernements de droite et de
gauche tentent d'y apporter des réponses
plus ou moins adaptés aux situations
réelles de nos concitoyens dans des
configurations
économique et de dépenses publiques
rares y ait la majorité précédente a
permis à différentes avancées du droit
des femmes c'est pourtant matière
salariale que ni l'égalité reste la plus
flagrante pour un travail égal le
salaire des femmes est encore de 28 %
inférieur à celui des hommes
cela restreint 6 il faut le rappeler
largement leur autonomie et leur
indépendance
80% des salariés à temps partiel sont
des femmes c'est aussi un frein à leur
carrière
quant à la représentation de ces femmes
au sein des structures politiques il
suffit de regarder certaines assemblées
et je n'en cite aucune pour comprendre
l'ampleur de l'inégalité
le groupe sauf peut être aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs le groupe ump n'aurait pu
être que favorable à un texte dont
l'ambition affichée de faire évoluer la
situation nous avons d'ailleurs
contribué à réduire les écarts existants
de nombreuses reprises il en va ainsi de
la loi hamlin relatives aux
rémunérations des femmes fixée lors des
négociations par branches
est ainsi de la loi sauvadet permettant
un meilleur accès aux postes à
responsabilité dans la fonction publique
en passant par la loi visant à lutter
contre les violences faites aux femmes
la loi relative à la représentation
équilibrée dans des conseils dans les
conseils d'administration
sur l'égalité professionnelle d'abord
ce texte comporte un début de réseau de
réponse intéressante qu'il s'agisse de
l'articulation des différentes
négociations sur l'égalité et les
salaires de l'est que de
l'accompagnement dé retour de congé
parental du renforcement des droits
familiaux des professions libérales de
la possibilité d'utiliser une partie des
droits du compte épargne temps pour
financer les frais de garde d'enfants
contre la précarité aussi le texte
apporte des éléments intéressants ainsi
l'expérimentation du versement en tiers
payant de la prestation d'accueil du
jeune enfant aux assistants maternels va
faciliter l'accès aux différents modes
de garde pour les familles modestes
contre les violences faites aux femmes
la confirmation le renforcement du
dispositif de l'ordonance de process de
protection pardon des femmes victimes de
violences sont à nos yeux
essentielles mais d'autres points de
votre texte madame la ministre
ne peuvent souscrire notre assentiment
au premier rang desquels la réforme du
congé parental rebaptisé prestation
partager d'éducation de l'enfant qui
n'est pas opportune selon ses modalités
à nos yeux ce n'est pas un scoop l'idée
d'un meilleur partage de cette période
entre les deux parents va dans le bon
sens mais nous ne croyons pas que ce
soit en nous immisçons dans la vie
privée de nos concitoyens et dans leurs
rapports familiaux que nous apporterons
une amélioration à la conciliation entre
vie professionnelle et familiale
votre projet madame la ministre risque
in fine et
d'accentuer les inégalités familial
entre les femmes et les hommes sur ce
point
revenons plutôt sur les causes poussant
les femmes à prendre le congé dans une
plus large proportion que les hommes les
familles en fête non trop souvent pas le
choix notamment pour deux raisons bien
entendu pour des raisons économiques
d'abord le salaire des femmes étant le
plus faible les familles ne peuvent donc
se priver de la plus haute rémunération
de plus
le coût des places de crèche ou auprès
des assistantes maternelles est quasi
inabordable pour certaines familles mais
également pour des raisons
d'organisation
ces familles n'ont pas souvent le choix
les places au sein des structures
d'accueil de la petite enfance manque
vous le savez bien car les collectivités
territoriales ne peuvent tout simplement
plus assumer la charge de besoin de plus
en plus important
puis comme nous l'avons répété lors des
deux lectures votre projet contient
aussi certaines mesures qu'on productive
à nos yeux ils risquent notamment même
et ce serait un comble de nuire à
l'emploi en rajoutant une condition
supplémentaire à la candidature à une
commande publique nous vous l'avons déjà
dit en première lecture je vous rappelle
qu'en 2012 sans 3000 entreprises étaient
concernées par les marchés publics pour
un montant de plus de 75 milliards
d'euros
ne croyez-vous pas madame la ministre
que ce faisant nous risquons de
fragiliser la sphère économique est
d'aboutir à une situation dans laquelle
les entreprises n'auront simplement plus
les moyens d'embaucher que ce soit des
hommes ou des femmes d'autant que
certaines entreprises ne peuvent pas et
c'est une évidence appliquer une stricte
parité et certainement pas dans des
délais rapides
en définitive madame la ministre
je pense que bien que pétri de bonnes
intentions
loin de la loire cadres attendus
ce texte est un assemblage je dirais
presque l'un de plus
assemblage de dispositions diverses qui
modifie pas moins de huit code et qui à
nos yeux ne s'attaque pas suffisamment
aux vrais problèmes culturels
qui sont de vrais pardon aux obstacles
culturels à la mise en oeuvre de l'ecde
de l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes il ne prend notamment pas
suffisamment en compte les demandes des
associations de parents ou de
professionnels j'ai donc peur que ce
projet ne soit un énième texte
législatif sur lesquels il nous faudra
une nouvelle fois revenir dans un
certain temps le pire serait en raison
d'effets négatifs sur l'économie ou sur
les finances publiques ou peut-être même
sur l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes avant de conclure je souhaiterais
en outre revenir sur un point qui nous
choque profondément
celui de la suppression de la notion de
détresse dans leur cour ali gvt et
la loi que vous allez voter aujourd'hui
ouvre désormais l interruption
volontaire de grossesse non plus
seulement aux femmes enceintes que leur
état place en situation de détresse mais
à toute femme qui ne veut pas poursuivre
une grossesse
législateur renonce ainsi à formuler les
raisons pour lesquelles interruption
volontaire de grossesse peut être
pratiqué il hilare il élargit les
possibilités d'accès à l'avortement à
d'autres motifs que la détresse de la
femme sent d'ailleurs les énoncés toutes
les motivations quelle qu'elle soit se
voit donc conférer une égale valeur
légale
cette rédaction à nos yeux soulève de
graves objections alors que
alors même que sa portée concrète n'est
probablement pas majeur puisque aucune
instance n'a aujourd'hui le pouvoir de
vérifier la réalité de la condition de
détresse telle qu'elle est posée par la
loi du 17 janvier 1975 relative à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
cette loi dite loi vaille cependant les
principes fondamentaux sur lesquels
repose cette loi va ils sont bien
remises en cause ses principes
fondamentaux que sont notamment le
principe du respect de tout être humain
dès le commencement de sa vie justifie
que l'avortement demeure aujourd'hui
légalement interdit hors les cas prévus
par la loi vague ainsi en l'absence en
vertu pardon de la loi pénale lorsqu'un
un avortement et pratiquer autrement
qu'en cas de nécessité et autres
manquent dans les conditions définies
par la loi il peut toujours être
sanctionné
la nécessité qui autorise l'atteinte au
principe se traduit depuis bientôt 40
ans par une exigence légale l'invocation
de sa détresse par la femme qui demande
d'interruption volontaire de grossesse
nous considérons donc au sein du groupe
ump que le principe du respect de tout
être humain dès le commencement de sa
vie n'est pas respectée c'est pourquoi
je vous annonce déjà que nous saisirons
le conseil constitutionnel sur ce point
le moment venu je vous remercie merci
monsieur le sénateur
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à madame muguette dini
pour le groupe udi uc
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues madame la ministre
nous avons travaillé ensemble lors de
votre première séance au sénat le 11
juillet 2012 sur le projet de loi
relatif au harcèlement sexuel et je suis
heureuse que vous soyez là dernière
interlocutrice de mon mandat de
sénatrice
pour en venir à ce projet de loi pour
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
vous le savez j'ai voté pour ce texte
lors des deux lectures dans notre
hémicycle
je ne reviendrai pas sur toutes les
dispositions que j'ai approuvé et sur
lesquels je me suis déjà longuement
expliqué en entendant notre rapporteur
je me suis dit que je l'avait échappé
belle parce que les recommandations de
1960 heureusement je ne les avais pas lu
c'est l'année où je me suis marié
je voudrais revenir sur deux ou trois
points du texte pour évoquer une
satisfaction 3 regret et une inquiétude
la satisfaction c'est d'avoir pu faire
prendre des dispositions spécifiques
concernant le congé parental des parents
de jumeaux et plus
les regrets
d'abord le maintien de l'adjectif réel
accolé au mot égalité comme pour le mot
laïcité je considère que tout
qualificatif à prouvy appauvri ces deux
notions
le deuxième regret le maintien de l'âme
et de la médiation dans le cas de
séparation d'un couple après des
violences conjugales je ne vais pas
développer j'ai déjà fait longuement
auparavant et le troisième regrets
l'incapacité à imposer dans la haute
fonction publique
ce que les entreprises doivent bon gré
mal gré mettre en oeuvre pour assurer
l'égalité dans leurs instances
dirigeantes et enfin une inquiétude la
difficultés qu'auront les parents à
organiser la prestation partager
d'éducation de l'enfant mais ce texte
est globalement une grande avancée pour
l'égalité femmes hommes dans le champ
professionnel
la protection des femmes seules la
protection des femmes victimes de
violences en particulier dans leur
couple et enfin de la parité
mon groupe sera donc majoritairement
favorables aux conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire mais je
voudrais profiter des quelques minutes
que m'accorde cette tribune pour évoquer
devant vous madame la ministre mes chers
collègues quelques réflexions de fin de
mandat et je commencerai par l'égalité
femmes hommes ce n'est pas seulement dix
ans de mandat sénatorial mais toute une
vie qui m'auront amené à constater que
ce combat car c'en est un n'est jamais
fini jamais gagné il demande un travail
constant une grande vigilance de la part
des femmes dont les plus jeunes mais
aussi des hommes encore trop rares qui
sont absolument convaincu que le respect
de l'égalité femmes hommes est une
chance pour notre démocratie et notre
société
ensuite je voudrais parler de notre
travail de sénateur et j'exposerai de
regrets le premier nous sommes des élus
expérimentés ayant une bonne
connaissance du terrain et beaucoup de
bon sens mais nous ne sommes ni entendu
ni écouter les conseillers des ministres
jeune et brillant mais totalement
déconnectés de la réalité
finissent toujours par avoir raison
j'accepte ce de ce ministère qui sont
très à l'écouté mais globalement j'ai
raison le deuxième regret
en dix ans de mandat je me suis rendu
compte qu'on avait toujours tort d'avoir
raison trop tôt que les suggestions
faites à un moment donné est rejetée
vont revenir de 5 10 ans plus tard que
de temps perdu et quel gâchis
enfin et c'est un voeu certainement
pieux mais il faut toujours espérer
j'aimerais que soient enfin prises en
compte par les gouvernements successifs
les excellents rapports généralement
présentés par deux sénateurs
de sensibilités politiques différentes
sans doute les textes de loi qui en
découleraient pourrait recueillir pour
la meilleure efficacité auprès de nos
concitoyens une large majorité
dans cette période de crise il serait
utile d'avoir ainsi un grand nombre de
textes de consensus national qu'une
grande majorité de nos concitoyens
réclame j'espère que vous pourrez madame
la ministre mes chers collègues dans
l'avenir contribuer à ce que cette union
nationale se met en place avant d'y être
contraint contraint par une crise encore
plus grande je vous remercie de votre
attention et je vous dis au revoir
merci madame la présidente
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à madame cécile du kerman
pour le groupe crc
la présidente madame la ministre mes
chers collègues le texte élaboré par la
commission mixte paritaire pour
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
quel terreau et elle tente de répondre à
des problèmes sociétaux
indéniable comme nous avons pu déjà
évoqué lors des précédents débats ici ce
projet de loi est la preuve s'il en
était besoin que les reculs les retards
et les écarts sont encore importants
matière d'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes dans notre pays nous devons
dans ce contexte restait plus que jamais
vigilants car nous avons pu le constater
encore aujourd'hui que certains à qui
pouvait être est rapidement être remis
en cause comme le droit à disposer de
son corps ou l'accès à l'ivg et nous y
étions
longuement revenus notamment en première
lecture à l'automne dernier notre pays a
pris du retard cela a été dit et les
chiffres le montrent en matière
d'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
il devient donc urgent et indispensable
de prendre certaines mesures pour rendre
cette égalité effective et sortir du
constat quasi annuel
d'ailleurs quasi rituel à chaque 8 mars
ce qui ramène d'année en année toujours
les mêmes chiffres avec finalement très
peu d'évolution c'est une question
fondamentale du présent et du devenir
pour notre société
nous savons que tous droits nouveaux
acquis par et pour les femmes
contribuent à un recul des dominations à
un pas vers une avancée de civilisation
ceci est d'autant plus vrai lorsqu'une
précieux écologique conservatrice se
fait de plus en plus forte il importe
donc de réaffirmer que toute avancée
progressive de notre société passe par
un avancé de l'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes c'est pourquoi nous ne
pouvons que nous réjouir de pouvoir
disposer d'une nouvelle loi qui annonce
un certain nombre de principes et prend
en compte un certain nombre de réalités
pour permettre réellement cette égalité
nous devons rester mobilisés pour qu'à
l'école par exemple cette éducation à
l'égalité puisse se poursuivre est
avancé et je l'espère madame la ministre
je n'en doute pas que vous resterait
vigilante quant aux projets et aux
ambitions annoncées aujourd'hui de
remplacer la bc de l'égalité par une
volonté de généraliser à l'ensemble des
enseignants donc à l'ensemble des écoles
donc à l'ensemble des élèves filles et
garçons cette sensibilisation à
l'égalité dès le plus jeune âge pour
leur permettre de se construire dans la
société de demain toutefois même si ce
projet de loi je les dis est un est un
bon début mes collègues du groupe crc
moi même pensons qu'il est indispensable
d'aller plus loin encore dans
l'affirmation d'engagement de mesures
parfois aussi dans la mise en place de
sanctions pour que cette égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes soient
respectés cette loi s'attache à rendre
effectives l'égalité dans plusieurs
domaines je ne les nommerai pas ils
l'ont déjà été précédemment par vous
même madame la ministre permettez moi
d'insister sur le monde du travail et de
ce que peut largement l'on appelle
l'égalité professionnelle
les chiffres sont assez révélateurs 50%
des femmes se concentre sur douze
familles professionnelles quand 50 % des
sommes se concentre sur vingt familles
professionnelles cette faible mixité ne
contribue pas à favoriser l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes est trop
souvent encore nous entendons de
nombreux stéréotypes sur certains un
certain nombre de métiers de plus dans
ces inégalités professionnelles
les femmes représentent 82% des
travailleurs des travailleuses à temps
partiel tout temps de travail confondus
nous constatons un écart de salaire dans
le privé de 24% entre salaire des femmes
et le salaire des hommes
nous savons cette situation est une
donnée clé pour comprendre y compris
allant dans l'ensemble de la société les
analyses les inégalités que cela génère
y compris dans ces périodes parfois plus
difficile de crise économique qui font
que in fine est dans la réalité pratico
pratique de la vie d'un couple c'est
aussi la femme qui sacrifie sa carrière
professionnelle déjà ma langue mal
commencé ou qui parfois fait aussi le
choix de se retirer de la vie
professionnelle parce que bien dans la
vie du couple est au niveau des salaires
le sacrifice entre guillemets est moins
important dans l'immédiat
quand c'est la femme qui le fait que
quand c'est l'homme nous avions donc à
travers ce texte la possibilité sur
cette question de prendre des décisions
pour que la force de la loi prévalent
sur le laisser faire et sur finalement
les conséquences du libéralisme qui
renvoie chacune et chacun a ses propres
choix alors que finalement les propres
choix de chacune et chacun ont un impact
réel sur l'ensemble de la société il est
de notre devoir de responsables
politiques de dire par la loi que la
règle n'est pas de proposer des emplois
à temps partiel aux femmes les obligeant
de fait à n'avoir que des salières des
salaires partiel avec deux fait
également des vies partiel et plus tard
de fait également des retraites partiel
d'ailleurs l'écart constaté sur les
retraites entre une femme et un homme
est énorme 932 euros pour les femmes
entre 1600 3 euros en moyenne pour les
hommes
temps partiel et précarité voilà le lot
de nombreuses femmes dans le travail
puis par la suite dans leur retraite or
nous savons et nous en sommes je crois
tout et tous convaincus ici que
l'indépendance des femmes passent par
une autonomie financière et que cette
autonomie financière se retrouve dans
l'activité professionnelle en grande
partie sans réelle sanction est en tout
cas ce que ce qui assure l'égalité après
les origines et les héritages de chacun
ne garantissant pas l'égalité sans
réelle sanction ce cercle vicieux
s'entretient voire même se développe
d'ailleurs je déplore que nous n'ayons
pas été plus loin dans ce domaine
notamment concernant la situation de
nombre aux femmes artistes et
professionnels du spectacle nous avions
en première lecture ici même au sénat
avancer dans ce sens il nous faut
également agir à la source
malheureusement dans une société très
patriarcales souvent c'est encore la
femme qui sacrifie je le disais et
parfois pour des raisons dans
l'immédiateté pratico-pratique sa
carrière professionnelle pour s'occuper
des enfants pour exemple taux d'activité
des femmes avec deux enfants en bas âge
chute à 70 6 66% contre 97 % pour les
femmes enfin alain amis nice
permettez-moi de regretter une dernière
fois ici que sur ces questions ce texte
se retrouve comme je lé rappeler
prisonniers du carcan de l'ani de la
réforme des retraites et d'une politique
d'austérité qui frappent nous ne savons
plus encore les personnes vulnérables
dont de nombreuses femmes victimes du
chômage du plafond de verre les quelques
dérogations visage à ces lois
antérieures qui construisent le système
en vigueur nous suffiront certainement
pas mais nous pensons cependant la miss
que ce texte est une première étape qui
entend a bouleversé la réalité les
mentalités et nous voterons donc ce
texte issu de la saleté
merci madame la sénatrice
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole et à madame anne marie
escoffier pour le groupe rdse
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois madame le rapporteur chers
collègues au cours et je regrette qu'on
puisse pas mettre collègues au féminin
et au masculin
mais vous êtes un mot commun c'est très
bien justement ça permet de bien montrer
de l'harmonie entre nous tous au cours
des dernières décennies la place les
droits des femmes dans la société
française ont connu d'indéniables
progrès pour autant nous le savons bien
les inégalités persistent et l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes demeurent
à l'horizon difficile à atteindre le
projet de loi que vous avez élaboré
madame la ministre est ambitieux il
aborde la question dans toutes ses
dimensions et ça je crois que c'est
vraiment un point fort est important
l'égalité professionnelle lutte contre
la précarité protection contre les
violences image des femmes dans les
médias parité en politique et dans les
responsabilités sociales et
professionnelles la tâche était
difficile car l'égalité ne se proclame
pas c'est un patient travail de fond qui
doit permettre de sortir des lieux
communs aussi madame la ministre
modifier en profondeur les comportements
notamment en matière d'égalité
professionnelle est un objectif louable
et nous y souscrivons pleinement je les
dis votre texte est ambitieux comporte
des avancées importantes notamment en
matière de lutte contre les violences
faites aux femmes avancé que nous
approuvons je me réjouis d'ailleurs que
les débats en première et en deuxième
lecture est enrichi ce volet
je pense à la généralisation du
dispositif de téléprotection femmes en
très grand danger à l'immunité pénale
pour les centres d'hébergement qui
accueille les victimes de violences a
l'obligation de formation sur les
violences faites aux femmes pour les
différentes professions qui
interviennent dans la lutte contre les
violences mais je pense également je
voudrais saluer le travail de françoise
laborde ma collègue qui a été
constamment sur ce dossier qui l'a
accompagnée qui l'a suivie et qui aurait
voulu être là aujourd'hui au moment où
madame la ministre mais qu'il n'a pas pu
et qui m'a chargé porter ses messages
donc je pense à l'amendement de madame
laborde qui modifiait la procédure
disciplinaire dans l'enseignement
supérieur et la recherche
il était nécessaire de porter une
attention particulière à la lutte contre
le harcèlement et les violences
sexuelles dans le milieu universitaire
face auquel les étudiantes se trouve
aujourd'hui nous le savons bien en
situation de vulnérabilité
il fallait mettre un terme à l'impunité
dont jouissent les auteurs de ces actes
les modifications apportées tant par
l'assemblée nationale que par le sénat
sont pleinement satisfaites je pense
aussi évidemment à l'obligation pour le
juge de se prononcer sur le retrait
partiel ou total de l'autorité parentale
un parent coupable de violences
intrafamiliales faisant ainsi écho à une
proposition défendue encore une fois par
françoise laborde en première lecture le
maintien de l'autorité parentale lorsque
de tels actes de violence sont commis
est incompréhensible et nous connaissons
bien les effets dévastateurs sur les
enfants tant sur leur personnalité que
sur leur développement
notre groupe madame la ministre se
félicite que vous ayez été sensible aux
préoccupations que nous avons soulevés
en première lecture s'agissant de la
délivrance de l' ordonnance de
protection à une femme menacées de
mariage forcé vous vous êtes engagé à
travailler avec le ministère chargé des
français de l'étranger à une meilleure
information des françaises et des
français concernés à un meilleur
accompagnement grâce à l'action de nos
consulats et je vous en remercie
je tiens enfin à saluer la position de
notre rapporteur qui sur le volet parité
a défendu une démarche pragmatique quand
les réalités sociologiques ne permettent
pas d'exiger une représentation
strictement paritaire comme vous le
savez nous pensons que la parité d'un
objectif certes tout à fait louable mais
qu'il serait excessif de vouloir
d'imposer partout et à tout prix la
parité ne peut pas s'imposer au
détriment du mérite et là je pourrais
faire de nombreux commentaires
s'agissant sur la parité dans le monde
de la justice dans le monde de
l'éducation nationale où j'aimerais bien
peut-être à titre personnel qu'un jour
on imposa un quota d'hommes et pas de
femmes le texte de la cmp n'a adopté que
quatre articles dans la rédaction du
sénat 4 / 30 c'est bien peu il est
dommage que les députés ne se soit pas
plus rangé à l'avis de notre rapporteur
s'agissant notamment du délit de
diffusion d'image de violence de la même
façon je trouve qu'il n'était pas utile
d'ajouter l'adjectif réel dans
l'intitulé du projet de loi et je
partage pleinement votre position
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois
l'adjectif vous l'avait dit et je le
reprends à mon compte n'apporte rien
d'un point de vue juridique et affaibli
le sens du texte nous regrettons fin
qu'au cours des débats la disposition
porté par le dr ds favorisant la
résidence alternée est finalement été
rejetée il s'agit pourtant d'un sujet
particulièrement douloureux qui aurait
mérité d'être abordée dans le cadre de
cette loi car si la justice ne doit pas
pouvoir imposer la résidence alternée
des enfants en cas de divorce rien ne
doit pouvoir l'empêcher lorsque l'un des
parents le demandent il y a aussi dans
ce domaine beaucoup de progrès à faire
pour combattre les préjugés et tendre
vers une égalité entre les hommes et les
femmes madame la ministre en dépit de
ces quelques dernières observations vous
aurez compris que mon groupe rds jeu
dans sa grande majorité
adoptera ce projet de loi mais il ne
faudrait pour moi même beaucoup de temps
pour
ajouté en mon nom propre celui
l'expérience d'une femme qui a toujours
combattu les excès ou qu'il soit à
quelque niveau que ce soit et qui
viennent rompre l' équilibre harmonieux
auxquelles nous devrions tendre l'homme
et la femme dans leurs différences mais
dans leur complémentarité avec leurs
talents et leurs compétences
seul critère qui me paraissent devoir
être privilégié au quotidien
merci madame la ministre
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole et mata mata michel meunier
pour le groupe socialiste
dames la présidente monsieur
président de la commission des lois
madame la ministre
madame
rapporteur mesdames messieurs chers
collègues nous y voilà nous examinons
donc aujourd'hui les conclusions de la
cmp sur le projet de loi pour l'égalité
réelle entre les femmes et les hommes
après des mois de travaux sur ce texte
la rapporteure pour avis que j'ai été
très fier et très heureuse que ce texte
de loi soit en voie d'être votée
définitivement
fier car je crois que notre assemblée a
bien travaillé et qu'elle a permis des
avancées sensibles sur plusieurs points
heureuse car ce premier texte cadre a
pour but de rendre réel l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes réels dans les
textes dans les têtes et dans les fêtes
et je me réjouis pour ma part que le
terme égalité réelle est été repris par
la cmp dans l'intitulé de ce projet de
loi nous savons que le chemin vers
l'égalité si chère à notre république
est toujours à emprunter et je dirais
particulièrement en matière d'égalité de
genre le pas que nous sommes en train de
franchir aujourd'hui est important afin
que les filles et les femmes de notre
pays puissent pleinement choisir leur
vie et vivent en égalité avec les hommes
et ceci dès le plus jeune âge et tout au
long de la vie que ce soit dans la
sphère professionnelle familiale
politique ou associatif il s'agit en
fait de permettre aux femmes de prendre
leur place pleine et entière dans le
fonctionnement économique social et
citoyen de notre pays et la société
toute entière
à y gagner
bien sûr il reste encore du chemin à
faire et il n'y a pas de fatalité il
nous faut du courage et de la volonté
pour faire changer les choses car c'est
une construction humaine qui induit qui
impose des comportements sexués aux
hommes comme aux femmes à partir d'une
différence biologique relatives à la
reproduction de notre espèce humaine
s'est installé un rapport de domination
des hommes sur les femmes dans toute la
société et nous pouvons donc changer ce
rapport est précisément comme il s'agit
d'une construction humaine nous devons
nous attaquer sans relâche aux
résistances aux préjugés aux habitudes
au réflexe il est de notre devoir de
parlementaire d'agir et de changer la
loi pour que les comportements évoluent
et c'est bien le sens de ce texte et du
travail que nous avons réalisé ensemble
pour le pousser plus loin encore et
mobiliser conjointement tous les leviers
pour faire appliquer les textes modifier
les comportements et atteindre enfin
l'égalité partout pour toutes et tous
l'analyse des mécanismes
discriminatoires nous a permis d'engager
une démarche originale à plus d'un titre
et ce texte cherche à rendre plus
effectif est plus appliqué les mesures
déjà existants en droit français et ce
texte permet également l'innovation et
l'expérimentation avant de généraliser
les mesures qu'il contient
l'article premier que nous avons
examinés dans le cadre de la cmp
résume bien l'objectif qui a quitté le
gouvernement et les parlementaires dans
la recherche d'un cadre cohérent pour la
politique conduite en faveur de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
une politique qui vise à lutter contre
la précarité des femmes à garantir
l'égalité professionnelle et salariale
ou encore à favoriser une meilleure
articulation des temps de vie et un
partage équilibré des responsabilités
parentales entre les pins mr une
politique aussi qui vise à renforcer la
lutte contre le système prostitutionnel
et à ce propos quelques mots puisque
vous connaissez mes convictions à la
matière et j'ai pu les exprimer en tant
que rapporteur de la commission spéciale
de nos récents travaux au sénat
j'estime comme sept inscrits dans la
formulation retenue en cmp que l'achat
d'un acte sexuel est dans tous les cas
une violence une violence contre
laquelle il faut lutter en s'attaquant
bien sûr aux réseaux mafieux de traite
des êtres humains mais également en
responsabilisant les clients qui ne sont
pas pour rien dans l'existence de ce
système prostitutionnel
nous aurons l'occasion madame la
ministre de débattre de ces points en
séance publique je le souhaite à la
rentrée prochaine
abordons maintenant le contenu du projet
de loi tel que nous a présenté
aujourd'hui tout d'abord les
dispositions en faveur d'un partage plus
équitable des responsabilités parentales
la mesure la plus emblématique d'entre
elles est l installation l'instauration
d'une période de partage entre les deux
parents des droit au complément de libre
choix d'activité
cela a été 10 96 % des bénéficiaires
actuels sont des femmes et l'article 2 a
pour but de rendre cette mesure plus
égalitaire en incitant les pères à
réduire ou à interrompre leur activité
professionnelle pour s'occuper de leurs
enfants et ainsi prendre toute leur
place dans la vie de famille mais il
s'agit aussi d'améliorer le retour à
l'emploi des mères qui le souhaitent et
ainsi contribuer à l'égalité salariale
et professionnelle entre les femmes et
les hommes l'égalité professionnelle est
justement le deuxième point que je
souhaite aborder certes les écarts de
salaires ont eu tendance à se réduire un
peu ses dernières années mais en 2014
une femme doit toujours travailler
77 jours de plus qu'un homme pour
toucher le même salaire à poste
équivalent le chantier n'est donc pas
terminée madame ministre pour parvenir à
l'égalité sur le terrain professionnel
le projet doit développe différentes
mesures bien ciblées
parmi lesquels rendre la commande
publique exemplaires vous en avez parlé
ne plus laisser les collaboratrices
libéral sans protection faciliter
l'articulation des temps de vie ou
encore inscrire endroits les conclusions
de la négociation nationale
interprofessionnelle
sur la qualité de vie au travail et
l'égalité professionnelle
à l'issue de la cmp nous avons également
attribuer un nouveau droit au pair à
l'article 2 bis b en autorisant trois
absences professionnelles pour se rendre
avec leurs compagnes aux examens
prénataux c'est à mes yeux une mesure
qui contribuent au partage plus
équilibré des responsabilités parentales
et ce dès les premiers des mois de
grossesse permettre ainsi au père de
prendre leur place avant l'arrivée de
l'enfant est une bonne chose aussi pour
la parentalité soutien à la parentalité
ce projet de loi je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure vise également à lutter contre
la précarité précarité qui touche en
premier lieu les femmes et le constat
est frappant une femme sur deux élevant
seule ses enfants déclarent ne pas
parvenir à boucler son budget sans être
à découvert le non paiement ou le
paiement aléatoire des pensions
alimentaires en cas de séparation est
loin d'être une exception
on le retrouve dans 40% des cas les
peines applicables sont lourdes en
théorie mais très rarement appliquée
rarement appliquée or ce sont de
nombreux enfants qui dans les faits vive
les situations de grande précarité voire
de pauvreté pour ne pas laisser ces
familles sans solution l'article 6
prévoit la mise en oeuvre via les caf
d'une garantie publique contre les
impayés de pension alimentaire et cette
mesure s'accompagne à l'article 6 70 s
d'une expérimentation du tiers payant
pour le versement de complément de libre
choix du mode de garde pour les familles
modestes cela limitera d'autant les
avances d'argent pour les familles y
veillant d j'ai très serré et nous avons
porté à 18 mois la durée de cette
expérimentation
je les dis cette loi est transversal et
a vocation à s'attaquer aux inégalités
partout où elles se trouvent c'est à
dire partout et ce texte vise aussi à
renforcer la lutte contre les violences
faites aux femmes comme vous madame la
ministre je constate ce continuum des
inégalités et des violences de notre
société qui maintient les femmes dans un
état de dépendance et d'infériorité
lutter contre les violences envers les
femmes ce n'est pas simple c'est même le
point de résistance de plus profond mais
agir pour l'égalité n'aurait pas de sens
si ce n'était pas pour éliminer les
violences changer les regards et les
mentalités et condamner les auteurs et
protéger les victimes l'ampleur des
violences notamment des violences
sexuelles subies par les enfants les
filles où les femmes sont elles que nous
ne pouvons pas les ignorer encore moins
baissé les bras ce sont des violences
exercées majoritairement dans l'espace
privé par des garçons des hommes proches
de leurs victimes et sans témoins la
situation d'emprise et de peur dans
laquelle les femmes sont maintenus les
empêche souvent d'en parler et de se
faire aider d'être accompagné or quand
elles ne sont pas traitées nous savons
les conséquences psychologiques
désastreuse qui subissent et qui perdure
toute la vie
nous ne pouvons plus accepter qu'une
enfant une jeune fille une adolescente
une femme soient exposés à la violence
du seul fait qu'elles soient de sexe
féminin c'est tout simplement
intolérable
je citerai quelques unes des mesures
contenues dans ce projet de loi le
renforcement de l'ordonance de
protection en réduisant les délais de
délivrance ou en prolongeant sa durée
d'effectivité
mieux définir les violences
psychologiques pour mieux les traités ne
plus proposer la médiation pénale comme
réponse à la violence conjugale faire de
l'éviction du domicile
le principe général et non son maintien
l'exception protéger les femmes en très
grand danger en les dotant d'un
téléphone d'appel d'urgence
assurer la gratuité des titres de séjour
pour les femmes étrangères victimes de
violences mieux responsabiliser les
auteurs de violences pour suivre les
plans de formation des professionnels au
delà ces différents points il me semble
important de veiller à l'application de
la loi et aux réponses apportées aux
victimes par le système judiciaire
victimes encore trop peu nombreuses à
dénoncer les auteurs de violence trop
peu nombreuses à porter plainte et trop
peu nombreux et trop peu d'acteurs
d'auteur pardon sanctionnés je
terminerai mon propos par la parité le
texte traduit en effet l'engagement du
président de la république de renforcer
considérablement les sanctions
financières pour les partis politiques
qui ne respectent pas leurs obligations
à la matière cette mesure est hautement
symbolique car le monde politique se
doit d'être exemplaire en matière
d'égalité
en effet comment encourager les
entreprises les structures sportives ou
médiatiques à agir pour l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes si les
instances politiques n'avance pas sur
ces questions de parité mais au delà de
la parité au sein des institutions
locales ou nationales qui avant ce
scrutin après scrutin du fait des
récentes réformes il faudra nous
attaquer lors de prochains rendez-vous
parlementaire à la parité au sein des
exécutifs et au partage de l'ensemble
des responsabilités le projet de loi est
en passe d'être voté il marque pour nous
la fin d'une étape et comme je suis d'un
intérêt l'inde un tueur l optimiste j'ai
envie de croire avec vous chers
collègues que ce texte qui a réuni un
fort consensus politique et qui nous
permet de franchir un pas considérable
nous engage encore plus et que le
travail ne pourra que continuer au delà
de la session parlementaire qui s'achève
nous pourrons reprendre ce chantier avec
enthousiasme et détermination à
l'occasion d'un nouveau cycle pour notre
assemblée qui débutera après les
élections sénatoriales et l'application
de son nouveau mode de scrutin ce sera
l'occasion mes chers collègues d'en
mesurer les effets et d'être enfin je
l'espère un peu plus que 23 % de
sénatrice dans cet hémicycle je vous
remercie
merci mme la sénatrice
la discussion générale est close je
rappelle qu'en application de l'article
42 alinéa 12 du règlement aucun
amendement des recevable sauf accord du
gouvernement le sénat étant appelés à se
prononcer avant l'assemblée nationale il
statue sur les éventuels amendements
puis par un seul vote sur l'ensemble du
texte
je ne suis saisi d'aucun amendement
conformément à l'article 42 alinéa 12 du
règlement je vais mettre revoir
l'ensemble du projet de loi dans la
rédaction résultant du texte proposé par
la commission mixte paritaire
y at il des demandes d'explications de
vote à madame vous voulez
oui mais le président même le ministre
mes chers collègues je pense que toutes
à peu près été été dit sur ce sujet je
n'avais pas l'intention de prendre la
parole mais en écoutant certains
orateurs et en fonction de mon parcours
personnel j'avais quand même envie de
vous dire plusieurs choses la première
c'est que effectivement on préfère tout
je suppose le combat aux quotas mais que
néanmoins sans sans quota il est
difficile parfois de mener des combats
car les obstacles sont nombreux pour les
femmes de façon à arriver aux
responsabilités ce n'est pas une chose
très simple parce que vous avez un sens
dit m des dom et lui depuis longtemps et
il faut passer à travers les fourches
caudines des partis politiques ou pas et
qu'effectivement je pense que le mode de
scrutin qui a été adoptée va permettre
de voir plus de femmes dans cet
hémicycle mais surtout
si beaucoup d'entre nous n'ont pas eu de
soucis beaucoup d'autres en ont et c'est
plutôt par solidarité que je veux très
ce texte et je voulais simplement
rappelé à l'assemblée que c'est le
centième jour aujourd'hui que des jeunes
filles nigérianes ont été kidnappés par
boko haram et que dans certains
pays de ce monde le fait d'être une
femme et n'est pas n'est pas très simple
a assuré que donc nous qui sommes ici
dans des conditions
extrêmement facile d'exercice de nos
droits nous devons penser aussi à celles
qui n'en ont pas dans une vie antérieure
mon ex compagnon me dois 18 ans de
pension alimentaire donc je vois aussi
les difficultés sur ce sujet et le texte
va sûrement là aussi améliorer un
certain nombre de choses donc pour pour
toutes ces raisons je voterai le texte
et la dernière raison est aussi un
hommage au travail de muguette dini qui
a décidé de ne pas solliciter un nouveau
mandat qu'elle aurait sûrement obtenu
haut la main
ll est une voix posée
délicate et énergique dans la défense de
nombreux droits on l'a encore vu il ya
quelques semaines sur les violences
faites aux femmes et je pense que sa
voix nous manquera dans cet hémicycle
merci merci madame la sénatrice je ne
vois pas d'autres demandes
d'explications de vote
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois vous avez la parole
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues je voulais
simplement dire que je voterai ce texte
avec beaucoup de conviction
parce que je pense en effet que ce texte
il contient en lui même tellement de
combat de lutte de mouvements
de difficultés
connues vécu porté par les femmes de ce
pays tout particulièrement pour cette
égalité
je le voterai nonobstant le fait qu'un
adjectif
et subsister malgré nos efforts au sein
de la commission mixte paritaire
je voulais donner là dessus quelques
explications
on croit toujours
qu'en ajoutant des adjectifs ou parfois
des adverbes on renforce le propos
mais tel n'est pas le cas
voyez-vous paul eluard
il a écrit un magnifique poème que tout
le monde connaît j'écris ton nom liberté
il n'a pas fait une ode à la liberté
réelle
véritable
authentique il y a des mots
qui ont une telle force
qu'il faut qu'ils s'imposent dans leur
plénitude
ainsi avons-nous défendu la laïcité
alors que certains voulaient que l'on
ajoute à cet adjectif positif la laïcité
positive ce qui présuppose est
inévitablement qu'il pourrait y avoir
une laïcité négative comme s'il y avait
madame la ministre
une égalité irréel
donc
je plaide bien sûr
mais ce pour quoi vous vous battez cher
michel besnier avec beaucoup de talent
c'est tout simplement l'égalité
la république n'a jamais souhaité que
l'on change à notre devise pour parler
de l'égalité véritable de la liberté
authentique et de la fraternité réelle
les mots ont un sens et nous en tant que
législateur nouveau nous devons
continuer cette oeuvre qui nous conte ce
qui consiste à n'être pas forcément
bavard mais comme le disait le grand
poète stéphane mallarmé à donner un sens
plus pur aux mots de la tribu donnons le
sens le plus fort possible à ces mots
comme le mot égalité et qu'il me soit
permis puisque j'ai la parole madame la
présidente et je vous en remercie
de saluer eu quelques personnes ne d'un
goulet a parlé de madame dini qui a mené
ce combat je voulais saluer
particulièrement eu madame prins elle me
le permettra puisqu'elle a choisi
de ne pas poursuivre son mandat qui a
mené avec beaucoup de force
ces combats pour les convictions qu'elle
porte en elle et vous me permettrez
aussi en ce jour de saluer l'action de
notre rapporteur j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure de notre rapporteur pour avis
mais qui restera au sénat mais je veux
parler eux de virginie klès et la
remercier très sincèrement
parce que comme j'ai eu l'occasion de
lui dire ce matin virginie klès et d'une
femme de convictions et qui a
constamment défendu ici avec beaucoup de
ferveur ses convictions et vous venez
encore une fois virginie klès en
apporter la preuve par votre
intervention doc soyez-en très
sincèrement remerciés merci monsieur le
président
je n'ai pas d'autres demandes
d'explications de vente donc je pars
donc vous avez compris tout le monde
aura compris
que rien n'ait été possible sans madame
la ministre najat vallaud belkacem
que je remercie également
parce que madame la ministre je puis
témoigner nous pouvons témoigner que
vous avez fait preuve d'une grande
ténacité pour que ce texte soit
premièrement élaboré deuxièmement
adoptée au conseil des ministres
et troisièmement qu'il trouve sa place
dans les agendas parlementaires
donc nous vous devons également
grand remerciement et vous voyez je me
permets d'ajouter en l'espèce un petit
adjectif merci monsieur le président en
sueur je suis saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public par le groupe socialiste
sur l'ensemble du projet de loi il va
donc être procédé au scrutin public dans
les conditions fixées par l'article 56
du règlement
donner le résultat du scrutin numéro 2
141 sur l'ensemble du projet de loi pour
l'égalité réelle entre les femmes et les
hommes dans la rédaction du texte
proposé par la commission mixte
paritaire
nombre de votants
344 nombre de suffrages exprimés
199 pour l'adoption
199 le sénat a adopté ce projet de loi
et je donne la parole à madame la
ministre
merci beaucoup madame la présidente bien
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
ne serai pas plus longue je vous dirais
simplement que dans la vie d'un ministre
d'une ministre et à quelques rares
moments d'émotion pure et que l'adoption
d'un texte de loi comme celui ci en est
évidemment un je veux vous remercier
pour la qualité du travail effectué ici
ces 24 heures j'ai calculé 24 heures de
débat tout compris c'est des amendements
nombreux qui ont été présentés mais 45%
de vos amendements ont été retenus et
sont venus enrichir ce texte c'est ce
qui fait aussi sa qualité aujourd'hui
donc merci et très longue vie à cette
loi
merci
madame la présidente comme monsieur le
président de la commission des lois je
me permets de reprendre la parole pour
vous saluer vous madame la présidente je
crois que c'est la dernière fois que
vous signalerez en tout cas comme
présidente dans cette assemblée et je
veux vous remercier pour la façon dont
vous l'avez fait avec beaucoup de
sérénité en nous rappelant à l'ordre
aussi souvent que possible mais c'était
nécessaire sur ces sujets sur lesquels
nous enflammons souvent merci encore
voilà donc pour l'adoption définitive
cet après midi par le parlement du
projet de loi égalité femmes-hommes plus
d'une année après sa présentation au
conseil des ministres on passe
maintenant un tout autre domaine un
autre sujet sur notre antenne avec la
discussion cet après midi au sénat de la
proposition de loi autour des taxis une
proposition de loi très attendue au
départ cette proposition de loi du
député thomas thévenoud été chargé un
petit peu de concilier les positions
entre les taxis et
vtc mais un amendement du même député
l'amendement 116 est venu semer un peu
la discorde pour rappel cet amendement
oblige les vtc à revenir à leur garage à
leur base entre deux courses alors on va
voir ce que devient cet amendement lors
de lors de la discussion cet après midi
au sénat notamment avec le sénateur
vincent capo-canellas bonjour merci
d'être avec nous vous aviez déposé en
commission deux amendements d'abord un
amendement pour supprimer cet amendement
sans cesse de thomas thévenoud et puis
finalement un amendement aussi de 2 de
repli pour essayer de trouver une
position de conciliation pour les vtc
sur ce retour ou non à leur base à votre
avis qu'est ce qui va se passer après
midi en séance quels amendements va
l'emporter tu es le rapporteur a émis un
avis favorable en commission ce matin
sur l'amour en numéro 8 qui les moments
de repli et je trouverais utile que le
sauna corrige la version qui est sorti
de l'assemblée nationale c'est ce qu'on
va essayer de faire tout à leur première
option c'est effectivement enlever ces
discussions qui est vraiment contestable
deuxièmement c'est la rendre un peu
moins effective elle a réécrit et faire
que pour les vtc se soit pas une
condamnation à mort c'est ce qu'on va
essayer de faire alors du coup quelles
dispositions pour les vtc est ce que ça
va les obliger à revenir à une base que
vont ils faire entre deux courses l'idée
cet amendement c'est que le vtc puisse
enchaîner dès lors qu'il aura un
deuxième client avec une réservation
qu'ils puissent rester sur la voie
publique ou restée sur le parking de
l'aéroport par exemple pour attendre son
deuxième client qui sont pas obligés de
revenir à la base dans ce cas là c'est
un moment de bon sens qui permettrait à
la profession de continuer à être
complémentaires des taxis sont deux
services qui peuvent vivre ensemble et
la proposition de l'hôtel nous a au
contraire essayer de faire pencher le
fléau de la balance trop dans le sens et
taxis il s'agit pas l'être au taxi ou
prou vtc il s'agit de permettre une
offre de mobilité à l'échelle de la
métropole d'aujourd'hui il faut du
transport partagé il faut penser à la
dimension écologique ce qu'on va essayer
de faire là en améliorant ce texte on
travaille dans l'urgence ça n'est pas le
plus simple mais simplement l'exercice a
beau être contraint il faut connaissait
au sénat d'améliorer ce que l'assemblée
a fait alors vous travailler dans
l'urgence est ce qu'il va y avoir une
suite à l'assemblée nationale assez
rapidement après le vote ce soir par le
sénat autour de cette proposition de loi
taxi la session parlementaire n'est pas
terminée le gouvernement peut très bien
décider
peut être soumise pour un vote conforme
à l'assemblée ça permettrait de clore le
sujet sinon il faudra reprendre le
travail à la rentrée parlementaire vous
semble que du côté de thomas thévenoud à
l'assemblée nationale il pourrait être
d'accord sur l'amendement que vous
proposez cet amendement de repli je
crois qu'il ya une prise de conscience
les bêtises et se sont exprimés il ya
des emplois en jeu plusieurs milliers il
s'agit maintenant de réparer une erreur
qui a été fait par l'assemblée il me
semble qu'un certain nombre de voix se
sont élevées et que les responsables
socialistes devront les entendre très
bien m'écouter merci beaucoup le
sénateur d'être venu nous expliquer un
petit peu votre position va maintenant
suivre la discussion générale d'abord
autour de cette proposition de loi et
puis ensuite la discussion autour des
articles et amendements et notamment le
vote concernant les vtc très bonne
séance à tous sens
bien la science est reprise et l'ordre
du jour appelle donc la discussion de la
proposition de loi adoptée par
l'assemblée nationale après engagement
de la procédure accélérée
relatives aux taxis et aux voitures de
transport avec show fort dans la
discussion générale la parole est à
madame carole delga secrétaire d'état
chargé du commerce de l'artisanat de la
consommation et de l'économie sociale et
solidaire madame la ministre vous avez
la parole
la présidente quelque chose
tiens
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
les clients comme les professionnels les
taxis comme les vtc qu'il s'agisse des
nouveaux acteurs comme des acteurs
historiques de la grande remise tous ont
intérêt à ce que une offre de transport
diversifiée et dynamique puisse se
développer dans notre pays après le vote
du 10 juillet au palais bourbon c'est à
vous mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
qu'il revient aujourd'hui d'examiner ce
projet qui vise à moderniser la
profession de taxi et à établir des
règles du jeu équilibré dans le secteur
du transport léger de personnes le
rapport produit par thomas thévenoud à
la demande du premier ministre en a
mille de 1 en avril dernier qui est à
l'origine de cette proposition de loi a
donné lieu à trente mesures concrètes
certaines font l'objet de textes
réglementaires et les services des
ministères concernés sont déjà mobilisés
d'autres peuvent faire l'objet de
dispositions législatives
voilà pourquoi nous sommes réunis ce
jour je voudrais vous exprimer ma
reconnaissance monsieur le sénateur pour
votre investissement personnel dans ce
dossier malgré des délais très contraint
vous avez tenu à rencontrer de nombreux
acteurs et à poursuivre le même
professionnalisme le travail mené par
les députés sur la proposition de loi
déposée par messieurs thévenoud et
l'euro
l'objectif de cette proposition de loi
est à la fois simple et ambitieux
moderniser une offre de transport léger
de personnes qui a considérablement
évolué ces dernières années avec de
nouveaux acteurs et avec le numérique
également trouver le juste équilibre en
dépassant les clivages et des idées
reçues pour ce faire un break un vrai
consensus social est nécessaire sur ce
sujet qui ne doit pas qui ne doit plus
se régler au travers d'appels à la grève
ou blogueurs blocage des rues de paris
pour cela et je mesure personnellement
ce que cette demande ne peut avoir
d'audacieux dans cette enceinte le
gouvernement souhaiterait que la haute
assemblée se prononce par un vote
conforme sur ce texte
pour qu aucune ambiguïté ne subsiste je
souhaite insister sur les raisons qui
justifient cette demande il ne s'agit
pas de considérer qu'aucune disposition
ne serait être mieux écrites et ça ne
s'agit pas non plus de brider
l'initiative du parlement d'ottawa qu'il
s'agit d'une proposition de loin et nous
ne voulons pas non plus nous montrer
irrespectueux du bicaméralisme qui est
l'un des piliers de notre république
il s'agit de se fonder sur l'existence
de cet équilibre qui a été recherché
collectivement c'est un équilibre
fragile parfois contesté mais c'est un
équilibre réel il s'agit de donner
aujourd'hui aux agents économiques
entreprises artisans ou salariés une
visibilité et une prévisibilité il
s'agit de continuer à travailler avec
des acteurs de terrain autour de
solutions concrètes pour améliorer la
montée en gamme des services de
transport
cette considération très pragmatique qui
nous a guidés qui amène le gouvernement
à solliciter de votre assemblée un vote
conforme je vais maintenant vous
présenter les différentes dispositions
qui vous sont soumises le premier
article cette proposition de loi ouvre
une véritable perspective de
modernisation avec le développement de
la maraude électronique la maraude c'est
à dire la possibilité pour le client de
et les véhicules sur la voie publique
est une fée spécificités propres taxi
elle pourra désormais se pratiquer
électroniquement c'est une vraie avancée
c'est aussi un service qui correspond
aux attentes des consommateurs et des
utilisateurs de taxi ce concept de
marans d'électronique c'est à dire la
possibilité de voir le taxi libre autour
de soi sur un écran de smartphone
constitue un atout sous un atout
supplémentaire pour cette profession ce
tel point que je voudrais insister même
s'il peut toujours y avoir une certaine
frilosité il est nécessaire d'avoir
certes de modernisation pouvoir
développer encore plus l'activité des
taxis des taxis cela répondra à une
attente et cela développera leur marché
la volonté du gouvernement de participer
au développement des usages du numérique
trouve une illustration pertinente dans
ce projet d'open data de la
disponibilité d haxhi c'est une
véritable innovation dont je souhaite
bien sûr souligné l'originalité et la
mission
résoudre un problème pâques par la
technologie c'est je pense une vision
progressiste et c'est une vision
d'avenir il est important que la
puissance publique puisse contribuer à
cette modernisation sam bien entendu se
substituer aux marchés l'intérêt de cet
open data est profondément double il
offrira en premier lieu les conditions
d'une amélioration réelle de l'accès aux
services transport de personnes tout
particulièrement dans les zones urbaines
il permettra aussi d'améliorer
l'information des acteurs publics du
transport et des mobilités ceci en effet
besoin de la connaissance la plus
précise de l'offre de transport pour
adapter celle des autres composantes du
service public des transports et
développer toutes les alternatives à
l'utilisation de la voiture individuelle
nous avons bien sûr en tête que tout le
processus de mise en oeuvre de l'open
data se fera dans le respect des
dispositions de la loi informatique et
liberté de 1978 qui constitue une
garantie de protection des libertés
individuelles
cette modernisation ne sera pas à
l'encontre des libertés individuelles je
tiens à vous l'assuré
nous avons pu entendre ou lire ici ou là
que le gouvernement voulait interdire
l'usagé des nouvelles technologies
et à la géocalisation donc pour les vtc
il n'en est rien il est évidemment hors
de question donc d'interdire ou vtc
d'être géolocalisé donc il sera bien sûr
possible pour le vtc d'être géolocalisé
mais les vtc ayant interdiction de
circuler en quête de clients et donc de
s'adonner à la maraude réservée aux
taxis ne doivent pas pouvoir être
signalée aux clients en temps réel sur
leur disponibilité
c'est à dire par le biais de la carte
leur smartphone en revanche les
entreprises de ce secteur demeure
parfaitement libres d'utiliser ces
technologies pour repérer au mieux leur
véhicule dans le cadre de leurs
activités dans un nouvel article la
proposition de loi il est prévu que le
gouvernement produise un rapport au
parlement sur la mise en place de l'open
data un an après sa mise en vigueur
votre assemblée pourra ainsi suivre en
toute transparence et la réalisation de
ce projet de modernisation
la profession des taxis avec des données
chiffrées sur la géolocalisation
lors du débat à l'assemblée nationale
nouvel article introduit sur proposition
du rapporteur
je le précise a par ailleurs rendu
obligatoire l'équipement des taxis avec
des terminaux de paiement électronique
afin d'améliorer le service pour la
clientèle et de moderniser l'image de la
profession nous sommes en effet
indispensable de pouvoir offrir ce
service et aux touristes et bien entendu
aux français la proposition de loi
s'attache également à moderniser des
conditions d'exercice de la profession
de conducteur et d'exploitants de taxi
certaines règles mériterait en effet
d'être précisées au bénéfice de ces
professionnels parmi les cinq ans et
demi le conducteur de taxi 8000 exerce
aujourd'hui leur métier avec un statut
de locataire qui constitue une source
d'ambiguïté et qui pénalisent les
chauffeurs en définitive ce régime
hybride fait du locataire un salarié au
titre la sécurité sociale est un artisan
pour les services fiscaux il rend les
locataires plus vulnérables aux
fluctuations de la conjoncture le
montant forfaitaire de 20 ans a quitté
l'île doivent dont ils doivent
s'acquitter étant indépendantes des
recettes réelles d'activité la
proposition de loi met donc fin à ce
système
remis en cause par les locataires
eux-mêmes au profit du droit commun la
location gérance
et au 1er janvier 2017 dernier délai la
location-gérance devra remplacer la
location simple ainsi il y à une mise en
oeuvre programmé dans le temps pour
cette nouvelle disposition cette
modernisation doit également permettre
aux taxis de participer à leur manière à
l'amélioration de l'image de la france
auprès des touristes des millions de
touristes étrangers arrivent chaque
année dans nos gares et dans nos
aéroports et c'est le premier contact
direct qu'ils ont avec notre pays le
mois dernier lors de la clôture des
assises du tourisme le ministre des
affaires étrangères et du développement
international a repris certaines
propositions du rapport thévenoud celles
qui portent sur la nécessité pour les
taxis de disposer d'une meilleure
visibilité dans les villes et celles qui
cherchent à faciliter les accès à la
capitale avec les couloirs réservés
m dans ce texte il est laissé le soin
aux autorités compétentes de fixer les
mesures d'identification des taxis en
respectant ainsi les compétences des
collectivités territoriales et à paris
de la préfecture de police dans ses
prérogatives d'autorité commune
au delà de moi la modernisation des
conditions d'exercice de la profession
de taxi cette proposition de loi entend
clarifier et renforcer les règles qui
s'appliquent aux transports de personnes
et singulièrement vtc au régime créé
récemment et jugé insuffisamment
protecteur pour le consommateur
la loi de 2009 dite loi novelli avait
pour ambition affichée de réformer le
statut de grand de remise s'adressant à
une clientèle haut de gamme sur un
segment du marché très particulier
il en a résulté une des rues la ration
des régulations quasi complète du
secteur cette loi crée le régime des
véhicules de tourisme avec chauffeur
bénéficiant d'un dispositif extrêmement
souple comme l'absence de comptes
qualification des conducteurs avec le
développement des smartphones où de
nouveaux opérateurs se sont implantés
sur ce marché qui connaît ainsi depuis
deux ans une forte expansion tout
particulièrement en région parisienne
le gouvernement ne souhaite pas traiter
freiner les initiatives ni entraver les
acteurs économiques répondre à de
nouveaux besoins au contraire les
services à la personne les nouvelles
technologies le numérique constitue
autant d'opportunités que le
gouvernement entend saisir ont contribué
au développement de l'emploi et de la
compétitivité de notre pays tout en
répondant aux besoins des consommateurs
toutefois les règles du jeu doivent être
clair pour tous est partagé par chacun
la liberté ne peut se faire au détriment
de l'égalité
dès 2013 nous avons pris des mesures
réglementaires afin de réguler cette
activité toutefois il est nécessaire de
fixer un cadre législatif ou vtc adaptée
à une activité de transport de personnes
il ne s'agit pas de créer une nouvelle
profession réglementée mais de fixer des
règles pour la protection des personnes
afin de garantir leur sécurité et leurs
droits en tant que consommateur vous
comprenez que en tant que secrétaire
d'état à la consommation je sois
particulière avait particulièrement
vigilante sur ce point
la protection de la sécurité des
personnes et la protection des intérêts
du consommateur sont les motifs
d'intérêt général qui justifie que les
activités de transport de personnes soit
réglementé l'assemblée nationale amender
les dispositions relatives au btc par
rapport à la proposition initiale du
rapporteur d'un côté elle a allongé la
durée de l'immatriculation des
exploitants de 3,50 de l'autre elle a
instauré une obligation pour les
chauffeurs de vtc à l'issue d'une course
de retourner au lieu d'établissement de
l'exploitant ou dans un lieu de
stationnement autorisé en dehors de la
chaussée il est utile d'ailleurs à ce
stade de rappeler certains principes
généraux sur l'activité de transport de
personnes sur la voie publique à partir
de l'exemple des taxis c'est pour des
raisons d'ordre public et d'intérêt
général que les taxis bénéficie d'une
autorisation de stationner sur la voie
publique et donc d'exercer la maraude
cette justification est d'autant plus
d'actualité dans nos villes et tout
particulièrement dans les métropoles où
la question de la fluidité de la
circulation était un véritable à le jeu
concrètement chacun d'entre nous peut se
rendre compte des conséquences sur la
circulation d'un des cas d'un véhicule
mal garé ou de l'espace ou dans un
espace non autorisées ça les stations de
taxis qui matérialise l'autorisation de
ses véhicules à bénéficier d'un espace d
préserver notre circulation en zone
urbaine serait encore plus compliqué et
anarchique la proposition de loi répond
au souci d' équilibre qui a traversé
l'ensemble débats préparatoires
renforcer les garanties profs des
professions de professionnalisme des
acteurs du vtc et renforcer la
responsabilité des intermédiaires tout
en se gardant des excès de
réglementation
elle entend maintenir cet équilibre par
l'introduction d'un certain nombre de
règles simples la capacité financière
des exploitants l'obligation de
vérification de la carte professionnelle
et de l'assurance par les intermédiaires
les garanties accrues du monopole des
taxis sur la maraude l'assemblée par
amendement a souhaité compléter les
garanties relatives au transport de
personnes pour des véhicules à deux ou
trois rues ou trois roues pardonne à
prendre improprement appelée moto-taxi
développé récemment cette activité
bénéficie d'un régime très souple sans
réelle garantie de sécurité pour les
clients ont jugé les députés ils ont
proposé donc d'y remédier
proposition de loi s'attache également à
faire en sorte que ces règles soient
respectées par tous c'est le sens de la
responsabilisation accrue des
intermédiaires qui bénéficiaient
jusqu'ici d'une relative impunité les
dispositions existantes visant soit les
exploitants soit les chauffeurs eux
mêmes il s'agit de dispositions
protectrices des consommateurs là aussi
vous comprenez que je suis tout à fait
clairement attentive la redéfinition des
infrastructures relatifs des infractions
relatives à l'offre frauduleuse de
transport permettra une répression
facilité du racolage les forces de
l'ordre sont d'ores et déjà mobilisés de
manière importante pour mettre fin à ces
situations qui portent préjudice aux
taxis comme en vtc qui respectent la
réglementation elles doivent avoir les
moyens d'exercer plus facilement leur
mission
ce texte prévoit par ailleurs une
intervention accrue de la dgccrf dont je
salue l'engagement sur ce dossier qui
contrôlera notamment l'application par
les vtc des règles relatives la
tarification en privilégiant
l'efficacité du contrôle de règles
simples un excès de réglementations sa
moyenne effective d'assurer le respect
le texte repose sur un équilibre auquel
le gouvernement souscrit pleinement je
tiens à souligner également l'efficacité
des forces de l'état qui ont été mis au
soutien de la démarche du député
thévenoud en particulier le service
national des enquêtes de la dgcrf
et puis nous avons bien sûr pu voir
qu'il y avait de nombreux manquements et
parmi les manquements les plus graves je
pense en particulier aux services hubert
pop qui ont bien sûr où il y a eu sur
ces mêmes commandes des procédures
contentieuses pour pratiques
commerciales trompeuses et s'inscrivent
dans des délais plus longs compte tenu
de la nécessité d'une intervention
judiciaire et surtout de l'absence de
sanctions directes pour l'organisation
de service illégal de transport de
personnes en effet le cadre en vigueur
ne me permettait pas aux forces de
police ou aux services du ministère des
transports d'intervenir contre hubert
mais seulement contre lectoure
conducteurs eux-mêmes victimes de ces
sociétés l'une des avancées notables de
la présente proposition de loi est
justement de venir combler cette lacune
dans la tente du vote la proposition de
loi je fais si toutefois de la diligence
des services de la dgccrf qui ont permis
dans un calendrier particulièrement
approché d'avoir déjà une efficacité
afin d'adapter le parc automobile du
transport léger des personnes aux
exigences environnementales et de lutte
contre les changements climatiques
l'assemblée a instauré un régime de
dérogation pour les véhicules hybrides
et électriques
je représentais hier soir fait cette
nuit plus exactement à l'assemblée
arnaud montebourg à l'assemblée
nationale sur la proposition de loi
bornes électriques de madame massat que
monsieur le rapporteur connaît bien
également car notre gouvernement
soutient à la fois sa dimension
écologique et industriels de telles
avancées pour marquer sa volonté de
simplifier le gouvernement a proposé de
supprimer le régime des petites remises
dans le cas de cette proposition de loi
il s'agit d'empêcher la création de
nouvelles petites remises en laissant
subsister celle estimée environ à 2000
qui existe encore aujourd'hui là encore
cette mesure vise à porter plus de
lisibilité plus de simplicité en évitant
ainsi les distorsions de concurrence
je me permets bien sûr pour conclure de
revenir sur la brièveté des délais de
préparation de cette réforme j'entends
bien les regret que vous formez en ce
sens renouvelant
mes remerciements à monsieur le
rapporteur pour le travail accompli un
peu de temps sur ce sujet dans la sa
forte sensibilité est connu le
gouvernement est bien sûr tout
particulièrement bernard cazeneuve et
moi même souhaitons accompagner le
parlement pour que des résultats rapides
sont obtenus c'est bien le soin le sens
de notre souhait d'un vote conforme sur
un texte nous avons le sentiment qu'il
est nécessaire que les règles permettant
une concurrence saine apaisé équilibre
et puis se mettre rapidement en place
porteur de création d'emplois tout en
étant protecteur des emplois qui
existent ce texte permettra de répondre
aux besoins de mobilité des citoyens
nous pensons qu'il ya une forme
d'urgence à ce que ce cadre soit encore
fixée de façon durable et permettent
l'épanouissement de l'ensemble offre aux
transports conformément à leur vocation
en s'appuyant sur les moyennes de
communication actuels s'il a le sens de
la position générale du gouvernement
c'est là le sens que nous avons souhaité
avec bernard cazeneuve sur cette
proposition de loi qui vous est
présentée ce soir mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs je vous remercie de votre
attention
merci madame la ministre
la parole est à monsieur jean jacques
filleul rapportant de la commission du
développement durable
bien madame la présidente
madame la ministre
chers collègues
2014 aura été jusqu'à présent une année
difficile
pour les taxis une année de conflit une
année de tensions
une année d'inquiétude et de
mobilisation face à l'émergence de la
concurrence
des véhicules de tourisme avec chauffeur
les vtc
et bien faisons en sorte mes chers
collègues que 2014 ce soit aussi l'année
de l'apaisement l'année des solutions
pour ce secteur si important pour nos
emplois pour notre vie quotidienne pour
le tourisme mais également la nouvelle
conception de la mobilité durable que
nous voulons promouvoir
il nous faut trouver ensemble tous quel
que soit notre banc une solution durable
pour un secteur où j'aurai l'occasion de
le redire il y à de l'activité pour tout
le monde c'est notre responsabilité
de législateurs aujourd'hui
si il y à de l'activité pour tout le
monde les professionnels le disent
eux-mêmes dès le 11 juin dernier encore
les taxis ont fait grève à paris mais
aussi à londres aaron et même à berlin
pour protester en particulier contre une
société américaine
qui via une application smartphone met
en relation des véhicules avec
chauffeurs et des clients permettant à
ceux-ci de géolocaliser les véhicules en
temps réel
ils protestaient notamment et il faut le
rappeler
contre le service hubert pop qui sous
couvert de covoiturage permet à des
particuliers
d'exercer une activité de faux taxi tout
en faisant payer
les personnes transportées
cvtc qui aujourd'hui se développe de
manière fulgurante
ont vu leur régime juridique assoupli en
2009 par lan/wan la loi novelli comme
vous venez de le rappeler madame la
ministre je le rappelle la procédure
d'immatriculation est purement
déclarative
auprès d'atout france
les conditions à respecter pour les
chauffeurs comme pour les véhicules sont
peu exigeante surtout si on les compare
à celles pesant sur les taxis
aujourd'hui et les contes sont quasiment
en temps réel ce sont 7745 entreprise de
vtc que l'on dénombre en france il y en
avait cinq fois moins il y a trois ans à
peine
face à ce rapide accroissement les
procédures d'immatriculation de vtc ont
été gelés en février 2014
après que le conseil d'état ait suspendu
en référé le décret du 27 décembre 2013
relatif au délai minimum de 15 minutes
entre la réservation préalable et la
prise en charge du client parle avait
décelé des vtc chacun ici s'en souvient
c'est en partie à cause de ce gel qu'on
nous a vigoureusement inciter à adopter
sans tarder cette proposition de loi or
il était surpris de découvrir
que 865 immatriculations avaient été
délivrés par atout france la semaine
dernière
le 15 juillet c'est à dire la veille
du passage en commission développement
durable
je l' ai découvert au début de la
semaine de cette semaine je tiens à
exprimer
solennellement au gouvernement montre
est vif regret de ne pas avoir été
informé en tant que rapporteur plus tôt
alors que alors même que nous avons eues
depuis un grand nombre d'occasions
de travailler sur le sujet il me semble
que cette information est essentielle
dans nos débats en d'autres termes je
considère que l'argument de l'urgence du
au gel des immatriculations que j'avais
avancé devant les collègues de la
commission
tient moins
forcément aujourd'hui
madame la mini je souhaiterais donc que
le gouvernement nous donne des éléments
d'explication et vous manquerez pas de
le faire plus précis car il est de notre
responsabilité
comme de la vôtre de veiller à ce que la
libération de ses immatriculations
ne viennent pas trop brutalement
déstabiliser un secteur déjà tendu mais
nous y reviendrons
oui excusez moi je suis sensible à la
fraîcheur et je trouve qu'il fait frais
dans cet hémicycle
ou bien le premier ministre oui quand je
suis avec axis leur donnant de fermer
les vitres
bien le prémice a donc confié
comme vous le savez au député thomas
thévenoud une mission de concertation
avec l'ensemble des professions du
secteur
taxicom vtc afin de trouver des
solutions pérennes à un conflit qui
pouvait sans doute se résumer de manière
très simple trop de rigidité et de
contraintes d'un côté celui des taxis
une trop grande souplesse et trop de
règles de l'autre celui des vtc la
proposition de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui est donc avant tout un texte
d'équilibré
les propositions du rapport thévenoud
remis en avril 2014 avait fait l'objet
d'un consensus de la part de l'ensemble
des acteurs du secteur des transports
léger deux personnes les taxis comme les
vtc
dans tout compromis
chaque disposition s'équilibre par
rapport à une autre la proposition de
loi
initialement dépoter déposée était le
fidèle reflet de ce rapport
elle a été examinée en première lecture
à l'assemblée nationale le 10 juillet et
les avancées qui ont été adoptés
respecter globalement l'equilibre
initial c'est pour cette raison que j'ai
proposé en commission une adoption une
adoption du texte en l'état
en effet j'ai pris le temps d'analyser
attentivement l'ensemble des points
majeurs proposés par le texte issu de
l'assemblée nationale j'ai rencontré
tous les acteurs organisés quatre tables
rondes entendu plus de 40 personnes de
la profession j'ai acquis la conviction
kung fu toutes les parties apprécier une
grande part des propositions
tout en sachant qu'en pareille
circonstance il est toujours courant
d'essayer d'obtenir plus
aussi au regard de ces rencontres et des
évolutions apportées au texte à
l'assemblée nationale j'ai considéré
qu'il avait conservé le point d
équilibre atteint lors de la grande
concertation du printemps dernier ce
point d'équilibré est très important
c'est lui qui fait en sorte que ce texte
ne met pas face à face
les taxis contre les vtc
ou l' inverse mais fixe des règles du
jeu stable et équitable pour tous
si j'ai proposé la semaine dernière que
notre commission
adopte la proposition de loi transmise
par l'assemblée nationale en l'état je
souligne que personne n'avait déposé
l'amendement sur ce texte pourtant
examinée selon la procédure habituelle
en termes de délai limite de dépôt
d'amendements notre commission n'a donc
pas modifié la proposition de loi mais
de nombreux collègues m'ont interrogé
sur certains points et en particulier
sur le compromis aux mises en oeuvre par
le texte les questions nombreuses
sur le sujet
ce qui est un sujet délicat
et complexes on peut tout à fait le
comprendre et je vais tenter d'y
répondre aussi dans ce texte c'est
pourquoi je voudrais apporter un certain
nombre d'éclairages sur les points qui
suscitent le plus de questions voire
parfois de polémique je crois que
certains des points font parfois l'objet
de confusion aussi ou même de fausses
informations vous allez apporter madame
la ministre certain nombre de précisions
peut-être apporterait il est même mais
en la circonstance je crois que c'est
pas c'est pas négatif de pouvoir rpt
dire exactement ce que contient ce texte
premier point
le système de registre
du registre de disponibilité des taxis
prévis prévue par l'article 1 oui ce
registre sera bien facultatif pour les
chauffeurs de taxi en outre il sera
contrôlé par l'autorité publique qui
garantira une protection des données
personnelles
un rapport introduit à l'assemblée
nationale à l'initiative de groupes ump
permettra d'en évaluer l'utilité et de
dresser le bilan
deuxième point oui le texte s'attaque au
problème essentiel du système de
délivrance des licences
avec ce texte c'est la fin du principe
de cessibilité dans la mesure où toutes
les nouvelles licences qui seront
délivrés ne seront plus ses cibles je
rappelle que cette mesure a été
préconisée par tous les rapports et ils
sont nombreux
publié depuis
fort longtemps je rappelle le rapport au
f de 1959 le rapport chassigneux la
commission attali et j'en oublie
certainement mais je vous rassure chers
collègues pour ne pas léser ceux qui se
sont endettés pour obtenir une licence
les licences déjà délivré reste ses
cibles
mais doivent satisfaire à des conditions
d'ancienneté que vous avez pu le voir
dans le texte qui sont relativement
confortables
ma troisième
planification concerne les différents
statuts des chauffeurs ce texte les
clarifie bien en allant dans le sens
d'un progrès social et humain
aujourd'hui il en existe trois puisque
un chauffeur peut-être artisans salariés
ou bien locataire demain il n'y aura
plus que deux
car le texte supprime le statut de
locataire taxi qui s'apparente et sa
parenté sur bien des points ce que
certains ont qualifié
d' esclavage moderne
mais pour que cette réforme ne soit pas
trop brutal vous l'avez vu dans le texte
elle a été aménagée
j'en arrive maintenant aux deux idées
aux idées reçues souvent relayées dans
les médias sur les articles de cette
proposition de loi relative au btc
premièrement il n'est pas exact
d'affirmer que la géolocalisation est
désormais interdite aux vtc vous l'avez
rappelé madame la ministre j'ai été
sensible et dans le texte de loi c'est
bien la maraude électronique qui leur
est interdite dans la mesure où la
maraude est et doit rester le monopole
réglementaire des taxis les vtc pourront
continuer à proposer une géolocalisation
de leur véhicule c'est d'ailleurs un des
éléments qui expliquent leur succès
commercial rapide mais les éditeurs
d'applications ne pourront plus
permettre à leurs clients de héler
électroniquement un véhicule à
l'extérieur
deuxièmement concernant la tarification
des prestations de vtc je tiens à
rappeler que la tarification
kilométrique est un des éléments
centraux de l'activité de taxi avec le
compteur horokilométrique or dans le
droit en vigueur les vtc peuvent
facturer au kilomètre parcouru le texte
répond à cette anomalie en leur
interdisant la tarification
kilométrique
en revanche il est important de
maintenir la possibilité de tarif et à
la durée les vtc et je pense en
particulier les vtc historique de la
grande remise
sont parfois amenés à effectuer des
prestations sur plusieurs heures
d'affilée voire des journées entières il
est nécessaire de leur laisser la
possibilité de continuer atari fier de
cette manière et d'exercer leur
profession par ailleurs je vous rappelle
qu'un décret devra fixer la durée
minimum minimale à partir de laquelle ce
mode de tarification est possible ce
sera donc en pratique un garde-fou
troisièmement je souhaiterais revenir un
instant sur ce que l'on appelle
couramment le retour à la base arrière
ce terme n'est pas dans le dans le texte
mais il est sous-entendu qui fait
beaucoup débat et qui sera j'en suis sûr
largement discutés lors de l'examen des
amendements
un amendement adopté en fin de
discussion en séance à l'assemblée
nationale prévoit l'obligation pour les
vtc de revenir à leur siège social ou
comme vous l'avez rappelé est très
justement madame la ministre dans à
partir parking hors de la chaussée à
l'issue de d'une prestation
cet amendement me semble participer de
l' équilibre fragile trouvé par les
députés sur la question sensible de la
maraude
soutien autour de la maraude ainsi que
l'expliqué thomas thévenoud dans son
rapport il est difficile de justifier
que les vtc ne sont pas en maraude
lorsqu'il circule sur la voie publique
on attend de réservation préalable est
qu'ils sont rendus visibles au
consommateur par des applications
smartphones la frontière est fine
chacun peut le comprendre le retour à la
base arrière permet de mieux distinguer
activité de taxi et de vtc nous aurons
l'occasion
d'en discuter à nouveau tout à l'heure
c'est un point important évidemment sur
lesquels nous examinerons très
attentivement les amendements qui seront
proposés pour finir j'aimerais dire que
la remise à plat des règles applicables
aux vidéos vtc dans cette proposition de
loi est la conséquence logique d'une
dérégulation poussé à l'excès lors de
l'adoption de la loi novelli ce que le
législateur de l'époque n'avaient
probablement pas pu et pas su anticiper
les vtc sont les premiers à prôner une
concurrence non faussée avec les taxis
sur le marché de la réservation
préalable le fait est qu'aujourd'hui il
opère dans un cadre réglementaire
permettant un certain nombre de
distorsion de concurrence en leur faveur
le texte n'a pas d'autre objectif que de
remettre les compteurs à zéro si je puis
dire et de rétablir l'égalité des armes
entre les acteurs je suis convaincu
qu'il en va aussi de l'intérêt de la
sécurité du consommateur
nous allons revenir tous ces points sur
tous ces points lors du débat que nous
aurons dans quelques instants mais je
tenais à vous apporter ces précisions
liminaire je suis sûr que nos échanges
que de nos échanges
émargera la solution de bon sens que le
sénat a toujours à coeur de rechercher
je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur dans la
suite de la discussion générale la
parole et à monsieur pierre charon pour
le groupe ump
madame la présidente
dans le ministre monsieur le rapporteur
ni chers collègues
je vais commencer par un compliment
cette proposition de loi est absolument
nécessaire
il existe depuis la loi du 22 juillet
2009 de développement et de
modernisation des services touristiques
un problème évident de rationalisation
de l'offre de transport léger de
personnes ce texte doit garantir le bon
développement des taxis et des véhicules
de tourisme avec chauffeur et assurer
une juste concurrence entre les deux
acteurs cette proposition de loi a été
discutée à l'assemblée nationale le 10
juillet dernier après engagement de la
procédure accélérée l'urgence ne doit
pas mener à la précipitation car malgré
l'adoption d'amendements nombreux le
texte est encore loin d'être parfait et
s'avère sur plusieurs points majeurs
trop contraignant et voilà que pour des
raisons de circonstance le gouvernement
voudrait faire adopter le texte sans
modification donc sans vrai débat
pourquoi le scénario serait-il à son
rôle de législateur en adoptant conforme
un texte rédigé uniquement à l'assemblée
nationale ce texte s'ouvre de
dispositions particulièrement les
favorable à l'esprit d'entreprise et les
contraire au développement de l'emploi
et de l'initiative individuelle alors
que dans le même temps le gouvernement a
la prétention de redresser la situation
économique ce texte doit permettre de
pacifier les relations entre les vtc et
les taxis de les finir durablement des
règles de concurrence juste entre les
deux acteurs une loi écrite trop vite
qui ne satisfait aucune des parties
prenantes ne peut être vu comme une
bonne solution en outre rien ne justifie
l'urgence d'une adoption définitive en
la fin notre session puisque toutes les
mesures du texte sont en application
pour mars 2015 le débat ne peut se
limiter à une opposition entre des
professions réglementées qui
refuseraient de s'adapter et obtiendra
gain de cause pour éviter la concurrence
de ceux qui se sont lancés dans de
nouveaux moyens de consommation il ya
chez la majorité des taxis une réelle
volonté de se moderniser et de s'adapter
aux demandes des consommateurs
il n'y a pas de tort pour l'une ou
l'autre des professions il faut faire en
sorte qu'elles puissent cohabiter
justement toujours au bénéfice des
consommateurs
si la concurrence déloyale eu certaines
sociétés de vtc étranger existe il faut
l'éviter faire en sorte qu'ils
appliquent la loi la stigmatisation de
certains ne doit pas faire oublier les
développeurs français vertueux comme le
cap stade car chauffeur privé à l'ocab
ou super chatel la liberté
d'entreprendre doit être préservée avant
tout si les vtc dispose effectivement
d'outils électroniques et d'une
réglementation qui leur confère un
avantage concurrentiel indéniable sur
les taxis ces derniers ne semblent pas
s'être adapté a si rapidement à l'ère
numérique le groupe ump et donc en
accord avec les auteurs du texte sur ce
qui concerne la modernisation de
l'activité de taxi nous sommes notamment
tout à fait favorables l'article 1er
vous avez évoqué monsieur le rapporteur
qui vise à créer un registre de
disponibilité des taxis et l'article 1er
bis qui doit permettre le paiement par
carte bancaire dans les taxis
mais ce texte instaure beaucoup de
règles supplémentaires de la contrainte
alors il faudrait au contraire davantage
de liberté et de flexibilité si les
dispositions à l'égard des taxis sont
généralement au bénéfice des
consommateurs les vtc sont malmenés par
votre texte vous voudriez tuer la
profession que vous ne vous y prendriez
pas autrement une disposition qui fait
débat au sein même de votre gouvernement
introduit une restriction générale la
liberté d'aller et venir des vtc et de
leur chauffeur l'obligation faite aux
vtc de rejoindre le lieu d'établissement
de leurs exploitants ou un stationnement
hors chaussée après chaque prestation
est inacceptable cette mesure qui leur
est imposée d'une contrainte que leurs
concurrents directs sur le marché de
réservation au préalable ne subissent
pas les taxis utilisant des centrales
radio en plus de les rendre moins
efficace la mesure entraîne pour les vtc
l'engagement de coûts supplémentaires
qui rendra leur activité impraticable il
convient de rappeler que le conseil
constitutionnel a clairement souligné
l'anti constitutionnalité d'une
interdiction générale de stationnement
sur la voie publique pour les motos
taxis
il ya aussi cette disposition ubuesque
qui précise c'est un vtc ne peux je cite
s'arrêter où stationner sur la voie
ouverte à la circulation publique à
l'abord des gares et des aérogares ou le
cas échéant dans le sein de celle ci au
delà d'une durée fixée par décret
précédent la prise en charge de clients
fermez les guillemets ce qui empêchera
comble de l'absurde de s'arrêter pour
laisser descendre son client avant
d'honorer la réservation suivante il
n'est vraiment pas raisonnable d'adopter
en l'état ce texte en réalité cette
proposition de loi touche à des domaines
variés le pouvoir d'achat les clients
pour qui le prix est une composante
essentielle dans le choix du mode de
transport l'emploi et l'activité de
notre pays c'est votre transport
constitue en effet les premiers contacts
pour les touristes et hommes d'affaires
en déplacement mais à dire vrai la
manière avec laquelle nous traitons ce
sujet et surtout révélatrice d'une
certaine conception de la concurrence de
la liberté d'entreprendre et de
l'innovation le développement des vtc
n'a jamais été un frein à celui des
taxis ils sont même complémentaires le
développement des deux acteurs est bon
pour le développement de l'emploi et
pour les usagers nous sommes tous ici
confrontés à la pénurie de l'offre de
taxis paris a aujourd'hui le plus
mauvais ratio de nombre de chauffeurs
par habitant inférieur même à des villes
de taille bien plus faible le
contingentement du nombre de taxis en
outre empêcher toute création d'emplois
en trente ans les deux tiers des taxis à
paris fonctionne aujourd'hui sur
réservation il y à 14 milles abonnés un
système de radio taxi le sénat en sait
quelque chose il fonctionne donc
essentiellement sur réservation un tiers
seulement fonctionnent en maraude la
conséquence pour le consommateur et la
cherté de la course à londres où le vtc
se sont beaucoup développées 20% des
plus défavorisés utilisent les taxis et
minitab une famille le plus que 20% des
plus favorisés parce qu'ils y ont accès
les plus défavorisés utilise le taxi
plutôt que de posséder une voiture qui
leur coûterait plus cher le taxi
parisien est à ce jour un service
destiné aux plus aisés
si l'offre de transport taxis et vtc
augmente les parisiens en useront ce
seront des déplacements plus rapides et
pratiques moins de pollution et une
circulation plus fluide il existe en
france dix acteurs majeurs du vtc qui
ont environ 3500 voiture dont 50% des
chauffeurs sont des professionnels
reconverti ces entreprises créent de
l'emploi et assurer leur chauffeur une
rémunération honorable plus de 400
emplois ont été créés par la société le
cab en un an et demi pour lui citer
qu'un exemple on peut raisonnablement
estimer à 10000 les créations d'emplois
dans les cinq ans ne nous empressons pas
de tuer ce qui marche notre pays ne peut
se le permettre pour toutes ces raisons
le groupe ump votera contre ce texte
s'il n'est pas raisonnablement amendé